85, ne? Chaosradio 85.
Eine annähernd disziplinierte Mannschaft.
Ja, außer die Mikrofondisziplin. Die leidet noch ein bisschen. Hol dir das Mikro doch mal ein bisschen näher ran, Andy. Zieh mal dran.
Aber wir müssen uns doch nicht heilen hier.
Das Knie, das ist das Knie. Das ist nicht die Knie.
So ein Beführerteil haben wir an allen unserer technischen Amtswoche.
Er ist doch mal richtig nah ran.
So ein bisschen so eine Handbreite. Ich hab gesagt eine Handbreite. Hand-Hund-Nase.
Ja, Hand so oder Hand so?
Schönen guten Abend, hier ist das Chaosradio Nummer 85. Worüber reden wir heute? Andy?
Ach man.
Also wir haben zwei Themen. Zum einen wollen wir heute gerne über Anonymizer reden und Anonymizer im Web, wofür wir die brauchen, was die tun und was man damit so anfangen kann.
Diese Stimme gehörte übrigens Frank. Ich stelle uns kurz mal vor, also im Studio sind wir zu fünft. Fefe, Frank, Andy und Hannes. Und die Knöpfe, das bin ich, die Knöpfe drückend, Holger Klein.
Der Knöpfchendrücker?
Wir haben extra viele Stimmen mitgebracht, um euch maßlos zu verraten.
Ist das nicht eigentlich echt peinlich, dass in der CCC-Sendung die Technik von einem Fritz-Mitarbeiter gemacht wird? Eigentlich sollten wir darüber nachdenken, oder?
Na ja, kommt ab, wir haben noch keinen Partner.
Fefe, dafür zahlen wir doch Rundfunkgebühren.
Ach ja, richtig.
Rundfunkgebühren zahlt ihr dafür, dass ihr überhaupt hier hinkommen dürft, Böhrchen.
Das tut doch nicht so, als würdest du Rundfunkgebühren zahlen.
Du zahlst keine Rundfunkgebühren?
Wir reden jedenfalls. Der zweite Teil der Sendung...
Warum hieß es im ersten Teil noch mal?
Der erste Teil der Sendung geht um Anonymizer. Das heißt darum, wie man im Web seine Spuren, also welche Informationen man im Web sich anguckt, so ein bisschen analysieren kann, um das andere nicht immer so einfach zu machen.
Das verhindert, dass andere Leute wissen, was man sich anguckt im Web zum Beispiel.
Der zweite Teil der Sendung geht um alternative Informationsquellen im Netz. Das heißt, wir versuchen ein bisschen zu beleuchten, was gibt es an Informationsquellen, Informationsmöglichkeiten, die halt außerhalb der Mainstream-Medien liegen. Wie wir den Sprung von dem einen Teil der Sendung zum anderen Teil der Sendung hinbekommen, da lasst euch dann überraschen.
Das machen wir ganz einfach dadurch, dass wir klarmachen, wozu man überhaupt Anonymizer braucht.
Andy.
Ach man, nämlich nicht Andy.
Wenn du das Mikrofon richtig ranholst, dann bin ich dich Andreas. Ja mach doch, du hast eine Struppe dran.
So lange du nicht mit dem Automaten-Kaffee wirst, ist das alles noch nicht unter die Genfer-Konvention.
Wenn ihr mehr wissen wollt, worüber wir reden, wir versuchen das jetzt wieder in der Musik herauszufinden. Ihr könnt ja auf Chaosradio.cde gehen.
Ach ja, da stand aber eben nichts von der Sendung.
Das ist heute Absicht, denn heute ist ein ganz besonderer Tag. Heute ist nämlich ein Tag der Proteste gegen E-Patente. Dazu gibt es einen Link auf der Homepage, die wir heute deswegen umgelenkt haben, wie übrigens auch viele andere wichtige Softwareproduzenten, freie Softwareleute.
Und überhaupt, das umgelenkt haben.
Genau, da ist eine kleine Zwischenpage, wo dann drauf steht, diese Seite ist gesperrt wegen Software-Patent-Protest. Und da ist dann auch ein Link drauf, um auf die alte Homepage zu kommen. Also der Inhalt ist jetzt nicht weg. Ach so, ich dachte das Internet ist schon kaputt. Aber nicht deswegen.
Die Musik kommt übrigens von Sven Dose.
Hannes ist sogar Professor an der Uni Regensburg und der ist der Initiator des JAP.
Das bedeutet so viel wie JavaAnon Proxy.
Genau, also ein Gerät, grob gesagt, mit dem ihr verschleiern könnt, was ihr im Netz gemacht habt, aber dazu später nicht. Pfeife wurde also freiwillig auserkoren zu wollen.
Genau, und zwar soll ich über das Camp was erzählen.
Ich soll?
Nein, also das Camp war diesmal einen Tag länger als...
Holger, jetzt bitte die Idee mit den Jubelpersern. Oh, warte mal, warte mal.
Den Applaus, genau, jetzt hier so das...
Warte mal gerade.
Also das Camp war diesmal einen Tag länger, aber hat halt niemand je zuvor hergesagt, deswegen war das auch nötig.
So, hier Applaus fürs Camp.
Ein bisschen sperrig.
Entschuldigung, ich muss ja auch sagen.
Hast du nicht noch irgendwas ein bisschen extatisch oder was?
So, warte mal hier.
Also wie war das Camp, Fife? Reicht?
Applaus aus. Ungefähr angemessen.
Ja, also das Camp war ganz wunderbar und das war eine große Aussicht. Also wer es noch nicht erlebt hat, das kann man in Worten und Grunde kaum wiedergeben, deswegen kommt unbedingt beim nächsten Camp. Und ja, also es gab da unter anderem ein großes Huxcenter, wo diesmal wegen der Hitze nicht so viel passiert ist wie in den Jahren vorher. Aber es gab dann doch sehr viele interessante Vorträge, was ihr auf unserer Webseite noch sehen könnt, das Inhaltsverzeichnis. Und es gibt im Web einige Fotogalerien von Leuten mit ihren Digitalkameras, die sind auch von unserer Webseite verlinkt. Kann man sich eine Impression abholen, gab eine coole Lightshow abends, gab, wie viel waren es insgesamt? 1800 Leute waren da, glaube ich.
War das viel? Also habt ihr mit mehr gerechnet?
Wir haben mit weniger gerechnet, ehrlich gesagt.
Naja, also mehr wäre schon besser gewesen.
Mehr kalkuliert, aber mit weniger gerechnet.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ah ja, verstehe.
Herr Vorsitzender, also ich empfehle jedem auf unserer Webseite, um an die Fotogalerien durchzuklicken. Es gibt auch ein paar Berichte, es gibt auch ein paar Berichte von Hackern, die zum Camp gekommen sind und da sozusagen Log geführt haben. Gibt es auch ein Web, könnt ihr auch mal Google fragen. Ich glaube, wir haben auch welche verlinkt. Und in der nächsten Datenschleuder wird dem natürlich gewürdigt werden. Genau, gebührend gewürdigt werden.
Wird dem gebührend gewürdigt werden.
Und gut, für den Vorträgen gibt es natürlich viele Dokumentationen auch online. Also diejenigen, die das Ganze verpasst haben, können sich sogar die Streams runterziehen. Deswegen springt unser ISP gerade ein bisschen im Dreieck.
Aber er hat es überlebt und Na der echte Ansprung kommt ja jetzt. Also so ab jetzt. Na weil wir gerade gesagt haben, dass es Streams gibt.
Chaosradio 85, nachdem wir also jetzt das Chaos Communication Camp gebührend gefeiert haben, kommen wir zum Thema.
Ja, wie schon erwähnt wollen wir uns heute so ein bisschen über Anonymizer unterhalten. Wir haben den Hannes zu Gast, der, ich weiß nicht, bist du Projektleiter bei JAP oder was ist deine Funktion?
Ja, es gibt zwei Projektleiter in dem Projekt. Es gibt einen technischen Projektleiter, das bin ich, und dann haben wir noch eine juristische Projektleiterin, die selbst allerdings Technikerin ist, aber die macht sozusagen die Betreuung der Begleitforschung im Projekt.
Und warum hat ihr dieses JAP Projekt angefangen?
Fangen wir vielleicht mal damit an, den Leuten, die es nicht kennen, zu erklären, was es macht.
Ja, es ist eine Software, die sich jeder kostenlos runterladen kann im Internet. Ich sage gleich mal als erstes die Adresse. Vielleicht für die, die es dann interessiert, wiederhole ich die dann später nochmal. Also www.anon, wie Anonymität, minus online.de. Also was macht die Software? Es ist eine Software, mit der man anonym durchs Netz surfen kann. Das bedeutet, dass wenn ich als normaler Benutzer mit dieser Software ins Netz gehe, dass niemand feststellen kann, welche IP-Adresse ich gerade habe. Ich habe zwar eine, die gibt mir der Internet-Service Provider und normalerweise würde ich bei jeder Anfrage, die ich ins Netz stelle, genau diese IP-Adresse mitteilen, sodass also alle Surfer, die ich kontaktiere, genau mitbekommen, welche IP-Adresse dazugreift. Nun kennt der eigene Internet-Service Provider natürlich die Adresse und möglicherweise ist die Adresse auch verketbar zu mir als Person. Wenn diese Verketbarkeit vorhanden ist, dann weiß man automatisch wofür sich jemand interessiert. Und wir haben uns nun gedacht, weil eben diese Verketbarkeit gefährlich ist im Internet, man muss dagegen was tun und haben eine Software entwickelt, mit der man genau diese Verbindung zwischen Name oder eben Identität einer Person und IP-Adresse verbergen kann.
Sprich, ich surfe ohne JAP zu www.fritz.de, dann kann der Webmaster von Fritz sich angucken, wer da gekommen ist, surfe ich mit JAP dahin, was sieht er dann?
Dann sieht er die Adresse, die unser Dienst hat, das heißt der Webmaster kann dann erkennen, dass ein Anonymisierer den Kontakt hergestellt hat. Mehr ist nicht mehr erkennbar. Und der Clou der Software ist im Gegensatz zu anderen Lösungen, wir sind ja nicht die einzigen, die sowas machen, dass auch wir als Betreiber nicht mehr in der Lage sind, zurück zu verfolgen. Wer hat was gemacht?
Und das soll ich dir jetzt glauben.
Das war der Stand der Dinge bis vor wenigen Wochen, kann man sagen. Und dann kam sozusagen die große Sache, die eben heute auch Gegenstand ist, über die wir reden wollen.
Ja genau, also ein Anonymiser hat natürlich viele Feinde, kann man ja schon so sagen, nämlich alle Leute, die sagen also naja, wer hat denn schon was zu verbergen und eigentlich muss doch irgendwie mal nachvollziehen können, wer da was im Internet tut. Was sagt ihr denn solchen Leuten, die sagen naja, so was wird doch eh nur von Kriminellen benutzt, die irgendwelche illegalen Machenschaften verbergen wollen?
Also zunächst mal spricht die Realität eine andere Sprache. Wir haben natürlich sehr genau, als wir angefangen haben, darüber nachgedacht, wer könnte so einen Dienst nutzen und haben zunächst mal einfach nur den Dienst angeboten. Wir haben die Software entwickelt, haben den Dienst angeboten und haben dann einfach mal geguckt, was passiert. Und es ist überraschenderweise relativ wenig passiert. Die Prophezeiungen waren, Anonymisierer wären nur für kriminelle Zwecke und Ähnliches verwendet, aber das hat sich so überhaupt nicht bestätigt. Es ist so, dass wir heute über diesen Dienst etwa 3 Terabyte an Daten transferieren. Das ist also eine Menge.
Täglich?
Im Monat. Ja, und diese 3 Terabyte, wenn man die jetzt mal hochrechnet auf die gesamte Zeit und dann auch die Anordnungen, die wir bekommen haben auf Herausgabe von Daten, die wir sowieso nicht speichern, dann waren das vergleichsweise wenig. Also wir haben etwa inzwischen 30 Anfragen bekommen, die wir alle abschlägig beantworten mussten. Das funktioniert typischerweise so. Die IP-Adresse, die unser Dienst hat nach außen, die ist ja nun bekannt, die wird dann mitgelockt, wenn jemand zum Beispiel einen Kreditkartenbetrug begeht. Und dann bekommen wir eine Anordnung, also eigentlich eine Anfrage, ob wir die IP-Adresse, die dem Urheber des Requests gehört, nicht herausgeben könnten. Nun sind wir ja ein Anonymisierer und haben die Daten nicht. Ihr habt die tatsächlich nicht. Wir haben die tatsächlich nicht. Das heißt, wir können jede Anfrage von Strafverfolgungsbehörden nur abschlägig beantworten. Und die Struktur des Dienstes ist auch so, dass man eigentlich solche Daten noch nicht mal leicht erheben kann. Also wir haben ihn extra so gebaut, dass eben nicht im großen Stil überwacht werden kann.
Was war jetzt sozusagen der Unterschied in der Anfrage, die ihr euch jetzt in den letzten Wochen in die Presse gebracht habt?
Der Unterschied war, dass wir bisher immer nur Anfragen bekamen, die die Vergangenheit betrafen. Da waren dann solche kuriosen Dinge dabei, wie Verdacht auf Abruf illegaler Inhalte mit Gefahr im Verzug und die Sache lag drei Monate zurück, um jetzt einfach mal einen extremen Fall zu nehmen.
Gefahr im Verzug vor drei Monaten?
Ja, das war natürlich ein extremer Fall. Der normale Fall ist, dass der Verdacht auf eine Straftat oder irgendeine andere kriminelle Handlung wenige Wochen oder auch nur Tage zurückliegt.
Wurde denn da jeweils spezifiziert, um was für illegale Aktivitäten es sich handelt? Weil es geht hier ja immerhin nur um den Abruf von Webseiten.
Typischerweise steht dann in solchen Auskunftsersuchen auch drin, was der Verdacht der Straftat ist. Also zum Beispiel Kreditkartenbetrug oder Computersabotage oder so. Zum Beispiel wird unser Dienst auch gern oder wurde gern benutzt, um zum Beispiel diesen Internet Information Server anzugreifen. Man schickt einfach dem eine URL und dann stürzt er halt ab oder macht irgendwas. Also solche Anfragen macht, was er nicht machen soll. Also solche Sachen kamen in der Vergangenheit. Und der Unterschied war jetzt nun folgender. Wir hatten von einem Mitarbeiter des Bundeskriminalamts einen Anruf. Und der fragte, was kann man tun, damit wir auch zukünftige Verbindungen überwachen können. Und dann haben wir mit dem darüber gesprochen, was theoretisch möglich ist. Die Dinge sind auch im Internet veröffentlicht.
Entschuldigung, was ist denn theoretisch möglich? Ich meine, das Ding ist doch dazu da nicht überwacht werden zu können.
Ja klar, aber so eine Technik hat natürlich auch ihre Grenzen. Es gibt in der Praxis keine perfekte Sicherheit oder wie man so sagt 100% sicherheit. Es wird also immer irgendeine kleine Lücke bleiben, mit der man doch noch angreifen könnte oder eben in dem Fall überwachen könnte. Man könnte zum Beispiel die verwendete Kryptographie, also die Verschlüsselungsverfahren einfach knacken. Das ist meistens sehr sehr aufwendig und in der Praxis überhaupt nicht tauglich. Man könnte aber auch zum Beispiel im System bestehende Schwächen, die man nicht wegkriegt durch einfach besseres Nachdenken oder so, ausnutzen. Und genau das war das, was wir auch hier vorgeschlagen hatten. Man muss sich Folgendes vorstellen, Anonymisierer funktionieren nach dem Prinzip, viele Leute benutzen die Software, dann werden viele Anfragen von vielen Benutzern über diese Software geschickt und hinten kommen dann die ganzen Antworten raus und man kann nicht mehr zuordnen, welche eingehende zu welche ausgehenden Anfragen gehört. Es ist also wie ein großer Topf, in den einfach alle Anfragen reingeworfen werden, dann wird kräftig durchgerührt, die Anfragen werden dann noch verschlüsselt bzw. in dem Fall entschlüsselt und deshalb kann man auch nicht rauskriegen, die, die vorher ein bestimmtes Aussehen, also ein bestimmtes Bitmuster hatte, entspricht genau einer Nachricht, die hinterher dann eben ein anderes Bitmuster hat. Diese Verkettung geht also einfach verloren. So weit die Theorie und wenn ich jetzt als Angriff, also zum Überwachen, einfach versuche alle, bis auf eine einzige Anfrage, die ich überwachen möchte, zu blockieren, sodass eben nur noch eine einzige Anfrage anonymisiert wird, dann ist nicht mehr viel anonym. Das ist ja gerade so, wie wenn ich als einzelne Person in ein Kaufhaus reingehe, dann ist klar, dass die Person auch irgendwann mal wieder rausgegangen sein muss aus dem Kaufhaus, wenn in der Zwischenzeit keine weiteren reingekommen sind. Und nach dem Prinzip kann man eine Deanonymisierung machen. So weit die Theorie.
Und die Praxis, die machen wir nach den Nachrichten, die kommen nämlich in drei Minuten, würde ich vorschlagen. Eine Frage noch für Leute wie mich, die der JAP, der ist clickybunti oder? Den kann ich auch bedienen.
Also wir haben ihn extra so gemacht, dass ihn jeder bedienen kann. Ich hoffe, dass er wirklich clickybunti ist, aber das können ja vielleicht die ganzen späteren Anrufer sagen, ob er wirklich so toll ist.
Dazu müssen sie sich runterladen, sag nochmal die Adresse.
Also www.anon-online.de.
Wenn Fritz in Panko, dann 102, 6.
Fritz-Info. Machst du jetzt das Wetter?
Kannst du mich hören? Also ich kann mich nämlich nicht hören.
Das macht nichts, wir alle können dich hören.
Entschuldigung, mein Kopfhörer ist gerade einfach mal ausgefallen. Das tut mir sehr leid.
Hast du das Kabel runtergefahren?
Nein, ich weiß auch nicht was das ist. Ich hab auf einmal gar nichts mehr gehört.
Dann hör dich.
So, 22.30 hier ist das Fritz-Info. In der Nacht gehen die Temperaturen auf 12 bis 8 Grad zurück. Morgen wenig Wetteränderung. Es ist heiter bis wolkig, aber überwiegend trocken bei den Höchstwerten um 22 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Karkauf.
Die Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt gegen einen Chefarzt wegen des Verdachts der Körperverletzung in mindestens 30 Fällen. Das berichtet der Tagesspiegel. Der Berliner Arzt soll regelmäßig zu spät im Operationssaal erschienen sein, da durch so die Narkose der Patienten unnötig verlängert haben, heißt es. Die Bundeswehr soll ihren Afghanistan-Einsatz über Kabul hinaus ausdehnen. Mehr als 250 Soldaten sollen noch in diesem Jahr zusätzlich in die nordafghanische Stadt Kunduz verlegt werden. Das hat das Sicherheitskabinett in Berlin beschlossen. Voraussetzung ist allerdings, dass die UNO die Erweiterung des Mandats billigt. Auf die Berliner Humboldt-Universität gibt es einen Ansturm von Studienanwärtern. Mehr als vier Bewerber kommen auf einen Studienplatz, sagte ein HU-Sprecher, rund 25.300 Interessenten haben sich für das erste Fachsemester beworben. Zum Sport im Nachholspiel der ersten Fußballbundesliga trennten sich Hannover 96 und Hansarostock 3 zu 3 unentschieden. In der Champions League Qualifikation zwischen Borussia Dortmund und dem FC Brügge stand es nach der regulären Spielzeit 2 zu 1. Momentan läuft in diesem Spiel die Verlängerung. Eine Verkehrsmeldung von der A12 bei der Ringrichtung Frankfurt zwischen Briesen und Milrose gab es einen Unfall. Der rechte Fahrstreifen ist blockiert.
Bitte Vorsicht.
Am Samstag ab 22 Uhr auf dem ehemaligen Militärflughafen Niedergörsdorf bei Jüterburg.
Hier hört Fritz das Chaosradio Nr. 85 im Studio FIFA Frank-Andy. Hannes von der Uni Regensburg und an den Knöpfen sitzt Holger Klein.
Ja, wir hatten ja vor den Nachrichten kurz darüber geredet, was so ein Anonymizer eigentlich tut. Vielleicht kannst du noch ein paar Worte dazu sagen, wie das eigentlich technisch funktioniert, weil mit einem so einem Suppentopf irgendwie kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass man es hinreichend anonym bekommt.
Also der Suppentopf, der Mix heißt, alleine würde nicht reichen, man braucht mehrere davon und diese Mehreren, die müssen auch noch von unterschiedlichen Betreibern betrieben werden. Ich versuche es mal mit zwei zu erklären. Angenommen, man hat zwei solche Suppentöpfe, die Mixer heißen. Der erste Suppentopf weiß, von wem die Anfrage kommt und er weiß, dass die Anfrage zu dem nächsten Suppentopf geht. Der zweite Suppentopf und letzte Suppentopf weiß, wohin die Anfrage geht, aber weiß nur, dass sie von dem ersten kommt. Folglich weiß niemand mehr die gesamte Verbindung. Voraussetzung dafür ist natürlich, dass Erster und Letzter nicht zusammenarbeiten, bei genau Zwei. Und bei Mehreren kann man sagen, es muss wenigstens einer in dieser Kette dieser Suppentöpfe sein. Suppentöpfe, wie kann man das nur Suppentöpfe nennen?
Nee, aber es funktioniert, ist ein schönes Bild.
Kannst du mal versuchen mit Suppentöpfen.
Ich hab Hunger.
Natürlich.
Also in der Kette dieser Mixe muss wenigstens einer sein, der nicht als Angreifer arbeitet. Das heißt, der tatsächlich anonymisiert und nicht seine Daten an die anderen weitergibt, damit eben enttarnt werden kann.
Und wie viel solcher Mix Server betreibt ihr momentan im Rahmen von JAP?
Also das kann jeder selbst überprüfen, indem er auf die bereits genannte Adresse, ich wiederhole sie nochmal, www.anon-online.de geht. Und da gibt es dann rechts unten so ein Statusfenster. Und momentan sind es eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf, zwölf Mixer. Allerdings nicht alle von uns betrieben, sondern gemeinsam mit Partnern. Wir haben zum Beispiel einen Partner auch hier in Berlin, an der Freien Uni Berlin. Es gibt einen solchen Mix, der in New York steht. Und unsere Projektpartner aus Kiel betreiben ebenfalls noch einen dieser Mixer.
Das heißt, man kann ja sagen, je mehr Mixer da mitmachen, desto anonymer wird es sozusagen?
Genau, das ist auch die Idee dabei. Je mehr es eben Sinn, umso unwahrscheinlicher ist, dass die alle zusammenarbeiten. Ich muss es noch etwas einschränken. Es kommt immer darauf an, dass in einer Kette möglichst unabhängige sind. Es genügt also nicht, dass einfach in der einen Kette ein paar sind und in der anderen Kette und die sind unabhängig, sondern man muss sich immer auf eine einzige Kaskade, wie wir so eine Kette auch nennen, beziehen.
Und wie viele Server habt ihr da so im Schnitt in so einer Kette?
Es sind momentan zwei beziehungsweise drei solcher Server.
Aus diesem Pool von den zwölf oder was immer gerade da online sind?
Genau und wir konfigurieren die auch vor, sodass man davon ausgehen kann, dass die unabhängigen Betreiber möglichst gut in einer Kette zusammenarbeiten können.
Und wenn man jetzt sozusagen ein bisschen feste IP-Nummern und ein bisschen Bandbreite über hat, kann man dann sagen, ich stelle euch da auch eins zur Verfügung?
Ja, ein bisschen Bandbreite reicht leider nicht, es muss schon erhebliche Bandbreite sein. Momentan werden über unser System etwa drei Terabyte im Monat transferiert. Hatte ich vorhin schon gesagt.
Herr Scharber, mit was für einer Außenbandbreite wird das denn für euch interessant, wenn ich da hinkomme und sage, ich würde gerne auch so ein Teil mit hinstellen?
Also etwa 100 Megabit pro Sekunde.
Und die sind dann auch voll ausgelasset?
Naja, am Anfang natürlich nicht, aber wenn sich's rumspricht und wenn der Server gut und stabil läuft, dann wird er immer häufiger genutzt.
Ok, ihr hattet ja jetzt dieses akute Problem mit den Strafverfolgungsbehörden, weswegen ja auch so ein bisschen in der Technikpresse erwähnt war. Vielleicht können wir das noch mal kurz einführen.
Ja, also es war so, ich hatte vorhin schon mal gesagt, dass wir in der Vergangenheit immer Anfragen von Strafverfolgern, auch von Privatpersonen bekamen, die eben Fälle, die in der Vergangenheit wiederum lagen, betrafen. Und jetzt hatten wir erstmalig einen Fall, wo es um Auskunftsersuchen ging für die Zukunft. Das heißt, wir hatten Kontakt mit jemandem aus dem BKA und der fragte uns, wie können wir hinkriegen, dass Webseiten, also konkret ganz bestimmte Server, kontaktiert werden und trotzdem rückverfolgbar ist, wer, also welche IP-Adresse, den Kontakt hergestellt hat.
Aber das war ja nicht nur eine Anfrage, das war ein Beschluss, oder?
Zunächst mal war es so, dass ein Kriminalbeamter vom BKA bei uns angerufen hat und gefragt hat, geht sowas überhaupt und wie geht sowas. Und dann hat er angekündigt, ja, er wird einen solchen Beschluss erwirken. Und es dauerte dann noch eine knappe Woche, bis wir den Beschluss auf dem Tisch hatten.
Was besagte der oder was kannst du uns darüber sagen, was der besagte?
Also zunächst war es so, dass wir, als wir den Beschluss bekamen, natürlich zum Stillschweigen verpflichtet waren. Es herrscht einfach der Grundsatz, dass man in laufenden Verfahren zur Verschwiegenheit verpflichtet ist. Es gibt im Übrigen auch noch einen Paragrafen in einem anderen Gesetz, der Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung, der eben besagt, dass man über laufende Überwachungsmaßnahmen keine Auskunft erteilen darf. Wir haben also deshalb erstmal nichts davon gesagt. Nachdem die Funktion aber eingebaut war, man muss vielleicht noch dazu sagen, dass die ganze Software als Open Source Projekt entwickelt wird. Das heißt, alle Funktionen, die in der Software enthalten sind, sind für jeden offen sichtbar im Internet, indem er sich einfach den Quellcode runterlädt und überprüft, was wir da eigentlich programmiert haben. Wir haben natürlich, nachdem wir diese Funktionen implementiert hatten, auch das ganz normal mit allen anderen Quellen, die entwickelt wurden, in dem Projekt veröffentlicht.
Also, das heißt, noch mal zurückgefragt, eine Funktion, die es ermöglicht zu feststellen, wer einen bestimmten von BKA benannten Server benutzt.
Genau, also in dem Fall war es einfach so, dass wir eine Funktion implementiert haben, mit der man dieses starke Sicherheitskonzept, das dahinter steht, hinter diesem Mix-Modell, so durchbrechen kann, dass man tatsächlich rückverfolgen kann. Allerdings nur unter der Voraussetzung, dass alle Betreiber von Mixen innerhalb einer Kette tatsächlich mitmachen. Das haben wir implementiert. Und dann auf diesen Beschluss gewattet, der uns eben so angekündigt wurde, dass wir es sofort handeln sollten. Das haben wir gemacht. Schließlich kam der Beschluss.
Wie ist es dann rausgekommen? Also ihr durftet es nicht sagen, das heißt, irgendjemand hat sich den Code angeguckt und gepetzt.
Dazu haben wir jetzt am Telefon einen Betreiber eines solchen Mixers, der sozusagen die Funktion, die das BKA gefordert und dann implementiert wurde, nämlich nicht bei sich installiert hat, weil er dazu ja nicht verpflichtet war.
Wunderschönen guten Abend, Gero Eggers. Jetzt müsstest du da sein.
Ja, ich bin da.
Ja, wunderbar.
Ja, vielleicht kannst du uns mal erzählen, wie dich sozusagen diese ganze Geschichte, wie sie dir zur Kenntnis gelangt ist.
Also ich hab das genauso erfahren wie alle anderen auch über die Presse und war dann doch etwas baff. Und ja, verstehen natürlich auch die Leute in Dresden, also die Entwickler, die diese Anordnung gekommen haben, dass sie sich da nicht strafbar machen wollten. Und wir haben uns dann bei uns zusammengesetzt. Wir sind ein Projekt an der Freien Universität, ein Studentenprojekt und wir haben uns zusammengesetzt, haben uns überlegt, wie reagieren wir drauf und haben gesagt, solange wir keine Anordnung erhalten und nicht gezwungen werden, bauen wir auch da überhaupt nichts ein. Denn so ein Anonymisierungsdienst muss halt möglichst vertrauenswürdig sein und wenn alle gleich im Vorhaus, allen im Vorhaus am Einbauen, dann ist das Vertrauen zum Teufel.
Kurze Zwischenfrage, wenn jetzt in diesem ganzen Pool von Mixen einer nicht mitspielt bei dieser Überwachungsaktion, funktioniert das ganze Ding dann überhaupt?
Dann funktioniert die ganze Überwachung nicht. Kann man auf den Punkt bringen.
Das heißt, was das BKA da veranstaltet hat, war völlig für ein Eimer?
Nein, nicht ganz, denn wenn die Kaskaden, die unter dresdner Kontrolle waren sozusagen, die haben überwacht, aber halt nicht, sind die, wo andere Betreiber mit drin waren, die den Code nicht eingebaut haben.
Das heißt, man sollte ja eigentlich als Organisationsmodell daraus die Schlussfolgerung ziehen, dass ein Modell, wo mehrere Server einer oder derselben Strecke vom selben Betreiber betrieben werden, ist sozusagen abzulehnen, wegen der Gefahr, dass dann ein solcher Beschluss wirksam werden kann?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist das Risiko, wenn man natürlich alle Mixer bei einem Betreiber hat. Technisch sieht es natürlich so aus, dass die Last natürlich recht groß ist, die auf so einer Mixkaskade liegt. Und da suchen wir natürlich auch gerne noch weitere potenzielle Betreiber, die mit uns Kaskaden aufbauen wollen, damit man mehr Kaskaden anbieten kann, damit man eben keine Kaskaden mehr hat, die zum Beispiel dann in Dresden heißen, sprich, wo bei einem Betreiber beide Mixe liegen, einfach aufgrund der Last, die da durchgeht.
Aber war es nicht so, dass sozusagen, weil die ursprüngliche Frage war ja, wie ist das Ganze öffentlich geworden, die Dresdner durften das ja nicht veröffentlichen, aber es war ja im Software Source Code eben ablesbar. War es nicht so, dass es durch einen Kaskadenbetreiber, wie du sie nennst, das Ganze sozusagen erst zur Presse gelangt ist oder habe ich das vom Ablauf her?
Soweit ich das verstanden habe, hat jemand das im Source gefunden. Also ein Dritter, kein Kaskadenbetreiber, hat es im Quellcode gesehen, der veröffentlicht wird und hat sich daraufhin an die Presse gewandt. Ich glaube im Konkreten, ich nehme an zuerst Heise oder es könnte auch sein, dass es über den Newsgroup gelaufen ist und dann über Heise.
Also ich kann es kurz mal erklären, wie es uns zumindest bekannt wurde, dass es bekannt war auf einmal. Wir bieten Jan Support an und es war eigentlich nur eine Frage der Zeit, wann irgendwann mal eine Meldung eingeht von jemandem, der sich den Quellcode tatsächlich anguckt. Und so war es dann auch. Wir haben also eine E-Mail bekommen von jemandem, der irritiert war über diese eingebaute Funktion. Sie war also nicht etwas so eingebaut, dass man sie nicht finden konnte, also wie ein drojanisches Pferd, sondern sie war sehr, sehr offen gekennzeichnet als so eine Überwachungsfunktion. Also gewissermaßen maximale Transparenz im Rahmen unserer Möglichkeiten. So, wir haben daraufhin geantwortet, dass dies tatsächlich eingebaut wurde von uns. Es hätte ja auch immer noch sein können, jemand hat unsere Server gehackt und da eine Softwareversion draufgestellt, die überhaupt nie von uns stammte. Aber das war nicht der Fall. Wir haben also ehrlich darauf geantwortet, ja, die Funktion wurde von uns eingebaut, durften aber natürlich in dem Moment immer noch nicht sagen, warum wir das eingebaut haben. Das war vermutlich der Punkt, an dem die große Irritation entstanden ist. Und hier muss man einfach sagen, wir waren ein bisschen unsicher, wie man eben damit umgeht, dass man einerseits Geheimhaltungspflichten hat, andererseits aber ein Open Source Projekt betreibt und natürlich von eben diesem Transparenzgedanken auch nicht abrücken will und auch nicht kann. Und dann haben wir eben im Grunde die Sache dadurch im Laufen gehabt, dass natürlich weitere Leute reingeguckt haben in den Quellcode, dann war es auf den ersten Foren drauf und so weiter.
Ich glaube, das war dann der Akku von Gero. Das tut mir sehr leid. Ja Gero, falls du das jetzt gerade hörst, danke, tschüss.
Hast du nicht nochmal diese Applaus?
Den habe ich jetzt gerade nicht auf Tasche. Wo waren wir? Was mich interessieren würde ist, warum habt ihr nicht einfach gepetzt? Ihr arbeitet den Code da rein, da ist doch bloß ein Anruf für dich, dass du sagst, Heinz Achmed, guck dir mal den Code an, da stimmt was nicht.
Das wäre ja illegal gewesen.
Eine Frage, die jetzt natürlich möglicherweise auch gekommen ist bei vielen, ist, was für Inhalte geht es denn da, wo das BKA einen richterlichen Beschluss erwirrt, dass derjenige, der nur lesen Zuwürf auf diese Inhalte nimmt, schon richterlich festgestellt sein muss. Und die Antwort ist so einfach wie verwirrend. Es geht wohl um kinderpornografische Inhalte. Also natürlich...
Moment, das BKA weiß, wo das Zeug liegt? Und möchte dann wissen, wer sich das angeguckt hat, anstatt zu dem auf die Finger klopfen, der das da hingelegt hat?
Exakt genau, das ist der Saatverhalt.
Haben die noch alle Tassen im Schrank?
Genau, das ist ja auch eine Frage, die ich an euch mal stellen wollte.
Könnte hier mal jemand vom BKA anrufen bitte und sich rechtfertigen?
Ja genau, weil wenn man so genau weiß, wo illegale Inhalte liegen, mit Alkinummer, dann müsste man doch auch gegen denjenigen vorgehen kann und nicht gegen denjenigen, der einen Anonymisierungsdauer betreibt. Habt ihr das dem BKA mal versucht, höflich aber doch bestimmt zu verkehren?
Also es ist wirklich wenig Spielraum hier mit dem BKA rum zu diskutieren oder mit den Leuten, die diesen Beschluss erlassen haben. Es ist einfach so, man bekommt so einen Beschluss und kann ihn gut oder schlecht finden und man muss ihn einfach umsetzen. Nun ist es in unserem speziellen Fall so, dass wir den Beschluss für so wie er ergangen ist, für rechtswidrig halten oder zumindest nicht für zulässig halten. Er ist ergangen nach einer Rechtsgrundlage, ich spreche jetzt als Informatiker und nicht als Jurist, nach einer Rechtsgrundlage und zwar ist es der Paragraph 100 GH STPO, also Strafprozessordnung, nach der man unseres Erachtens einen solchen Beschluss, wie er dann formuliert war, überhaupt nicht stellen darf. Also was da in diesem Paragraph 100 STPO GH muss ich dazu sagen, was da drin steht, passt einfach nicht zu dem, was am Ende angeordnet wurde. Richtiger wäre hier der Paragraph 100 AB, es ist also im Grunde Buchstabenfuchserei, was hier betrieben wird im Moment von mir, ein solcher Beschluss hätte ergehen müssen und dann wäre die Sache vermutlich einwandfrei gewesen.
Ihr habt doch jetzt auch gerade Recht bekommen, vorgerichtet an dieser Stelle.
Das kann man so nicht sagen. Also die Sache wurde eben sofort von uns erst mal mit einer Beschwerde belegt. Wir haben also uns dagegen gewehrt in Form einer Beschwerde. Das ist das sogenannte förmliche Rechtsmittel, das man einlegen kann. Das hat aber keine aufschiebende Wirkung. Das heißt, wir waren trotzdem gezwungen, sofort die Sache umzusetzen und haben das auch gemacht. Und nun ist es so, dass gerade heute, zufällig heute, vielleicht auch absichtlich heute, wir ein Fax bekommen haben, in dem drinsteht, dass der Beschluss ausgesetzt wird. Das heißt also, alle Überwachung muss gestoppt werden, bis eine endgültige Entscheidung der nicht höheren Instanz, in dem Fall des Landgerichtes in Frankfurt am Main, ergangen ist.
Also sehe ich das richtig, dass wenn die das jetzt, also das Landgericht Frankfurt-Main, wenn die jetzt beschließen, dass das rechtens ist oder dass diese Überwachung stattzufinden hat, dann dürft ihr wiederum nicht sagen, dass es jetzt wieder stattfindet.
Das könnte man so interpretieren, allerdings ist es so, dass unsere Juristen und es sind nicht wenige und es sind wirklich schlaue Köpfe, aber es ist halt nun mal ungeklärtes Feld letztlich. Inzwischen der Meinung sind, man darf sehr wohl sagen, dass man eine solche Funktion hat und dass eine solche Funktion auch aktiv ist, was man geheim halten muss und ich glaube, das ist eine Selbstverständlichkeit, welche Anschlüsse, also konkret welche IP-Adressen überwacht werden und dann natürlich auch welche Daten da aufgezeichnet wurden.
Naja, aber so selbstverständlich finde ich das nicht, weil immerhin liegt ja hier so ein bisschen der Verdacht im Raum, dass das BKA diesen Beschluss gegen euch nur erwirkt hat, um einen Vorwand zu haben, euren Dienst A zu diskreditieren. Weil es haben sich ja viele gefragt, nachdem das sozusagen eben nicht durch euch bekannt wurde, sondern dadurch, dass es jemand in eurer Software gefunden hat, da haben sich ja schon viele gefragt, Moment mal, wenn ein Anonymisierungsserver eine sozusagen Datenzuführungsfunktion hat, dann ist es ja kein Anonymisierungsserver mehr und dann hätten doch eigentlich diejenigen, die das Ding betreiben, als ehrliche Menschen das Ding einfach abschalten sollen.
Ja, da kommen wir doch jetzt ganz schön in den Bereich der Konspirologie rein. Oder ich glaube nicht, dass da jemand das Ding diskreditieren will. Das BKA denkt sich mutmaßlich...
Aber Holger, du selbst hast gesagt, wenn das BKA so genau weiß, auf welchem Server Inhalte liegen, deren Verbreitung illegal ist, warum gehen sie Gottverdammt nicht gegen diesen Server vor?
Na, weil das BKA in dem Moment, wo es überwachen kann, wer auf diesen Server zugreift, natürlich jede Menge andere Verbrecher findet. Also das heißt, die Frage ist, ob die das überhaupt dürfen.
Du meinst, wenn sie sozusagen einen Heroinhändler sehen und sie haben mehr Nutzen davon zu sehen, wer das Heroin kauft, weil dann haben sie... Ja, aber das ist doch eine merkwürdige... Also ich meine, gut, ich bin auch kein Jurist, aber...
Ich weiß nicht, wo dieser Server steht. Also je nachdem, wo er steht, haben sie keine Handhabe und wollen darum wenigstens die User in Deutschland haben.
Die Kinderpornografie ist weltweit illegal. Also die Verbreitung von Kinderpornografischen Bildern ist in jedem Land auf dem Planeten mit dabei.
Verfolgt doch mal einen in Russland, bitte.
Tatsächlich, die größeren Kinderpornobusts waren alle international, die haben alle mitgespielt.
Also deswegen, das ist tatsächlich kein Argument.
Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, also bei besten Willen nicht, dass da jemand bei BKA so sagt, ha ha, jetzt diskreditieren wir mal.
Also wenn du überlegst, was irgendwie die großartige Kooperation des FBIs mit dem russischen Geheimdienst zum Transport von Luftabwehrraketen in die Vereinigten Staaten neulich irgendwie gebracht hat, dann traue ich denen einfach mal genau alles zu.
Wir reden vom BKA.
Also ich sag mal jetzt als einer der Verantwortlichen dieses Projektes. Ich sag mal als einer der Verantwortlichen dieses Projektes, dass das natürlich vermutlich keine Rechtsgrundlage hätte, wenn man so was macht. Wir persönlich gehen als eben Betreiber davon aus, dass natürlich die Gesetze genauso eingehalten worden sind seitens der Strafverfolger, wie wir eben die Gesetze eingehalten haben.
Man Holger, Entschuldigung.
Ich hab nicht gelacht.
Mach unsere Gäste nicht fertig.
Mach ich doch gar nicht.
Hilf dir der Polizei und so.
Hilf der Polizei, verprügelt dich selber.
Chaosradio 85, über JAP, den Anonymizer reden wir. Eine technische Frage hat der Mike, namens Mike. Ja, schieß los.
Folgendes, Frage vorweg, diese Anonymitierungssurfer...
Kannst du ein bisschen lauter sprechen bitte?
Hallo, die Anonymitierungssurfer, Frage vorweg. Hab ich einen Einfluss, wie viel, ich sag mal, Subtöpfe dahinter sitzen, wenn ich mir da einen aussuche? Ja, nein.
Ja, normalerweise sind es wohl zwei, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab, ne?
Okay, wie ist das, ich sehe gerade TU Dresden, das sind drei Stück, die haben alle, ich sag mal, ca. den selben Adresspool. Kennt ihr, ich sag mal, einen elektronischen Verkehrsdienst im Internet, dem das nicht gefällt, dass jemand anonym surft, einfach diesen Adresspool spermen, sprich, filtern, und dann sitzt er entgegen, wir dürfen rocknen, ist Daniel.
Ja klar kann er das machen. Im Gegenteil, wir bieten sogar für diejenigen Webseitenbetreiber, die gesperrt werden wollen, also die nicht über unseren Anonymisierer aufgerufen werden wollen, einen entsprechenden Sperrdienst an. Die müssen sich einfach bei uns melden, dann wird das manuell überprüft, ob das korrekt ist, also ob die ihre eigene Webseite tatsächlich sperren wollen und dann sind sie gesperrt. Prinzipiell ist natürlich es auch möglich, dass dieser IP-Adressbereich unseres Dienstes von demjenigen Serverbetreiber gesperrt wird.
Nehmen dann einige diese Sperroptionen in Anspruch tatsächlich?
Also meistens wird sie dann in Anspruch genommen, wenn irgendwelche Dinge passiert sind, die die Serverbetreiber nicht wollen, zum Beispiel wenn Adressbucheinträge über den JAP gemacht wurden von Leuten mit irgendwelchen Beleidigungen oder irgendwelchen Grimskraums und in so einem Fall wenden die sich dann an uns und bitten eben darum zu sperren.
Ich rede hier immer gleich von irgendwelchen kriminellen Nachenschaften. Mein Problem ist ja einfach nur, jetzt wie am Anfang gesagt wurde, eben nur einfach mein Verhalten zu erforschen. Was für was interessiere ich mich? Wo suche ich welche Seite? Und alleine das kann doch jetzt sagen wir, ein oder wenige fallen und entspannen einfach diesen Anonymisierungssurfer. Und dann habe ich die Informationen doch nicht bekommen, auch wenn ich dann anonym bin. Da muss ich eben doch halt dieses Tool dann deaktivieren und dann dort eben, ich sage mal, legitim die Information abzurufen.
Ja gut, aber es gibt ja auch viele, die die Information sehr wohl verbreiten wollen, aber wo die Abrufe ein Problem haben. Zum Beispiel, wenn du am Arbeitsplatz Information abrufst, die Firma Siemens selbst, jetzt ja beispielsweise unternehmensweit, wie heißt dieses Ding jetzt gerade diese Woche? Früher hieß es mal Smartfilter. Das Produkt ist dann verschieden umgenernt worden. Und zumindest vor einiger Zeit war es noch so, dass man von Siemens Arbeitsplätzen auf keine Website von Gewerkschaften aufrufen konnte, weil die entsprechend sozusagen als nicht wünschenswerte Verschwendung von Arbeitszeit gesperrt sind. Und auch an so einer Stelle kann natürlich so ein Anonymizer helfen, weil der eigentliche Webverkehr zwischen dem Benutzer und dem ersten Server läuft da verschlüsselt ab und entsprechend greifen die auf URL-Erkennung von hier.
Würde Siemens sowas gestatten?
Also Moment, deine Frage war doch letzten Endes, was nutzt man so einen Anonymizer, wenn der Webseitenbetreiber, auf den ich anonym zugreifen will, sagen kann, ich will aber nicht anonym zugegriffen werden, richtig? Das Problem ist natürlich, dass du als Betreiber eines solchen Services musst du dich natürlich in einer gewissen Umgebung bewegen. Und wenn das dir wirklich wichtig ist, auf diese Webseite anonym zuzugreffen, kannst du halt immer noch in Sinterheit-Café gehen. Also ich denke, dass man da halt immer so eine gewisse feine Balance wahren muss. Vielleicht kann Hannes ja noch was dazu sagen. Was man jetzt Leuten zugesteht und wo man sagt, okay, da sehen wir einen, es gibt da möglicherweise ein Problem und deswegen sperren wir diese Webseite für den Zugriff durch den Anonymizer.
Also das ist so ein bisschen wie auch mit den Cookies. Es gibt nicht wirklich eine Notwendigkeit, heute Cookies einzusetzen. Trotzdem setzen sehr viele Betreiber Cookies ein, meistens um Leute zu beobachten. Es ist natürlich aus Sicht von Datenschützern, auch aus meiner Sicht, nicht in Ordnung, dass das gemacht wird. Aber Cookies wurden nicht erfunden, um Leute zu beobachten. Sie haben durchaus auch sinnvolle und praktische Anwendungen, positive Anwendungen. Gleiches könnte man hier argumentieren. Also ich denke ehrlich gesagt gerade ein bisschen um die Ecke für dich, damit du sozusagen auch ein bisschen verstehen kannst, warum wir diese Sperre anbieten. Man könnte jetzt auch sagen, es gibt durchaus schutzwürdige Interessen bei dem Surferbetreiber, dass eben diese Inhalte nicht zugegriffen werden können über unseren Anonymisierer oder über irgendeinen Anonymisierer. Genau für solche Fälle bieten wir die Sperre an.
Noch eine Frage, die mir gerade einfällt, wenn ich das Q jetzt auf meinem Rad da einset, funktioniert mein Esel dann noch?
P2P Netzwerke, funktionieren die?
Da kenne ich mich nicht aus. Nein, es geht nicht, glaube ich. Also diese Software, die wir entwickelt haben, die bietet nur HTTP an zum Anonymisieren und HTTPS.
Ich habe heute Nachmittag mal in die FAQ geguckt, es funktioniert nicht. Also kein P2P, kein idonki, kazao oder sonst was.
Genau, es gibt aber eine Funktion, die eben aufgrund des hohen Missbrauchspotentials momentan ausgeschaltet ist. Alle Anwendungen, die Socks fähig sind, können theoretisch anonymisiert werden. Socks ist so ein allgemeines Firewall-Tunneling-Protokoll. Ist aber nicht aktiviert in der aktuellen Version. Bitte was?
Müsste ich mir dann den Kreut anscheiden, um das zu aktivieren, oder habt ihr das da gerne rausgenommen?
Also klein-seitig würde es dir nichts nützen, wenn du es aktivierst. Da müsste der Code drin enthalten sein, weil dazu eben auch auf Server-Seite ein entsprechender Surfer laufen müsste, der dann dieses Protokoll umsetzt. Ein sogenannter Socks-Proxy.
Aber es ist eine gute Idee, es hat sicherlich noch diverse, ich sag mal, Motivationen gegeben von sicherlich in irgendeiner Form.
Also das hoffen wir auch, dass die Software von anderen wirklich angeschaut wird und weiterentwickelt wird.
Alles klar, Mike, danke für deinen Anruf.
Zwei Minuten nach elf, Chaosradio 85, Blue Moon.
Anonymizer, unser Thema im Allgemeinen und der JAP im Besonderen runterzuladen, wenn ihr es euch angucken wollt, installieren wollt und auch mal die FAQ lesen wollt unter www.anon-online.de. Chaosradio 85, mein Kopfhörer geht schon wieder nicht. Es ist echt klasse. Erzählt mal was Jungs, ich versuch nur meinen Kopfhörer in Ordnung zu bringen.
Felix, du wolltest noch was erzählen. Ich wollte noch was sagen. Ich bin zwar nicht der offizielle Pressebeauftragte vom CCC, aber ich habe das dringende Bedürfnis an dieser Stelle, dem JAP Projekt, dem Anon Projekt, einen virtuellen goldenen Pokal zu überreichen, denn wenn ich der Programmierer wäre, da kann sich jeder Hörer mal reindenken, und das BKA ruft an und sagt, ihr müsst ihn jetzt überwachen, aber ihr dürft keinem was erzählen, dass ihr das dann ins CVS tut, was weltweit abrufbar ist und es halt praktisch indirekt eben doch veröffentlicht. Da gehört schon eine Menge Mut zu und ich muss sagen Hut ab an der Stelle. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das auch gemacht hätte, weil da hängt ja dann noch einiges von ab. So richtig klar ist das nicht an der Stelle, dass man das einfach bequem und gefahrlos tun kann und deswegen an dieser Stelle einen Applaus von uns an das Projekt.
So und weiter im Text. Anonymizer ist unser Thema im Chaosradio 85 und der JAP insbesondere im Studio neben FIFA, Frank und Andi auch Hannes von der Uni Regensburg. Der ist da Professor für IT Sicherheitsmanagement und einer der Initiatoren von JAP. Ich hab hier gerade einen Anrufer mit einer Detailfrage. Fragen wir mal, was er im Detail wissen will. Hallo Roman.
Ich wollte mal gerne wissen, warum diese Programme, dieses JAP nicht funktioniert, wenn ich Kasa starte. Das ist ein Filesharing.
Ich bin doch Prof, ich weiß so Zeug nicht. Nein, also es ist irgendwas mit Filesharing, irgendwas mit kriminellen Inhalten. Spaß beiseite. Also normalerweise dürften die sich nicht stören. Es könnte sein, dass du einfach irgendwie die miteinander in Verbindung gebracht hast. Auf jeden Fall darfst du nicht glauben, dass du diese Kasa-Dinge alle über JAP machen kannst. Das eine hat mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun. Vermutlich sind es Unverträglichkeiten, die so miteinander nichts zu tun haben. Du empfindest es nur als solche.
Ja, also Filesharing und JAP geht nicht zusammen.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass man beide Programme auf dem Rechner nicht gleichzeitig haben kann und benutzen kann. Das heißt nur, du kannst nicht darüber eben P2P-Dienste nutzen.
Ich bin froh, dass mein Kopfhörer jetzt wieder funktioniert.
Jetzt den Applaus für Heuers Kopfhörer.
Wo ist denn der Applaus für meinen Kopfhörer? Da ist der Applaus für meinen Kopfhörer.
Die Frage, die man sich natürlich stellen kann ist, warum du nicht ins Mikrofon sprichst. Entschuldigung, weil das hier zu wenig Mikrofonen gibt.
Ja, jetzt keine Ausreden hier.
Die Frage, die man sich natürlich stellen kann ist, was für Inhalte eigentlich vorstellbar sind, wo man als Betreiber selbst vielleicht doch ins Grübeln kommt. Sind für dich da, oder ihr habt da intern sicherlich einiges diskutiert, sind bei euren Diskussionen da irgendwie auch so Sachen zu tal kommen, wo denn einige gesagt haben, also dafür möchte ich aber meine Birne nicht enthalten.
Könntest du das nochmal konkretisieren, was du da gefragt hast?
Na ja, wir kommen ja jetzt mit der BKA-Geschichte, da können wir ja nur Rätsel raten. Wir können sagen, das BKA ist gekommen, hat gesagt, hier ist auf einem Server kinderpornografisches Material und ihr müsst feststellen, wer mit welcher IP-Nummer auf diese Inhalte zugreift.
Haben die überhaupt gesagt, dass da Kinderpornografie drauf ist?
Ja, das haben sie.
Es ist so, dass in diesem Beschluss tatsächlich steht, dass es sich um den Verdacht einer Straftat nach diesem entsprechenden Paragrafen handelt. Das ist auch in der Pressemeldung so veröffentlicht worden, insofern, um jetzt einfach mal auch immer diese konspirativen Dinge gleich von der Hand zu weisen. Also wir haben dann in dem Moment, wo wir wussten, dass wir darüber auch sprechen sollten und auch dürfen, schon auch alles offen gelegt, was offen zu legen war. Interessanterweise ist allerdings dieser Aspekt der Kinderpornografie gar nicht von uns offen gelegt worden, sondern das hat wohl ein Sprecher des Landgerichts in Frankfurt am Main wohl auf Auskunft der Presse eben gesagt. Aber es deckt sich jedenfalls mit unserem Beschluss.
Ja und trotzdem ist die Frage natürlich offen, wenn dem BKA die IP Nummer eines Servers bekannt ist, wo eindeutig Kinderpornografisches Material abrufbar ist, wo ja sogar schon der Besitz dieses Materials strafbar ist, warum gehen sie da nicht gegen den Server vor, der das verbreitet, warum gehen sie gegen diejenigen vor, der einen Dienst betreibt, mit dem man verschleiern kann, wer darauf zugreift. Da können wir jetzt Rätsel raten, da kannst du mich jetzt der Conspirologie beschuldigen oder was auch immer.
Aber du gehörst sowieso zu denen, von daher ist es...
Zu welchen auch immer.
Mensch, Holger.
Aber die Frage, die natürlich im Raum steht, gibt es eigentlich überhaupt vorstellbar sozusagen Inhalte, jetzt mal nach gesundem Menschenverstand und nicht nach Juristerei gefragt, wo man sozusagen als Betreiber oder potenzieller Betreiber sagen würde, dafür will ich aber ungern so einen Service betreiben. Habt ihr da so intern diskutiert, als ihr das Projekt angefangen habt?
Also man kann natürlich irgendwelche Moralvorstellungen jetzt gleich äußern. Das führt aber nicht so sehr weiter. Also hier helfen dann wirklich nur wiederum Tochblicke in irgendwelche Strafgesetzbücher oder andere Gesetze. Also klar ist, bei Kinderpornografie hört irgendwie auf jeden Fall der Spaß auf. Ich glaube kaum, dass da irgendjemand, der halbwegs normal ist, andere Meinung ist. Es ist sicherlich die Frage, gerade aus der Sicht, ich glaube wir sind hier in einem Radiostudio, wo Musik gespielt wird, aus der Sicht der Musikindustrie, ob also illegales Runterladen von irgendwelchen Musikstücken, die man eigentlich kaufen müsste, legal ist. Das lässt sich alles diskutieren, aber das ist ein weites Feld. Und ich meine, man sollte sich auf diese Diskussion auch nicht unbedingt einlassen als Betreiber von so einem Dienst. Wir haben auch irgendwann mal konsequent gesagt, wir machen hier keine Zensur für Inhalte. Wir sagen, alle Inhalte können über unseren Dienst abgerufen werden. Jeder, der allerdings eine Sperre haben möchte, dass er seine Inhalte nicht über JAP abgerufen bekommt, kann das bei uns beantragen. Aber es gibt keine Sperren außerhalb sozusagen irgendwelcher, zum Beispiel auch Anordnungen wieder von Gerichten oder eben Anfragen von Nutzern. Das denke ich ist legitim. Alles andere würde dann eben uns nur den Vorwurf der Zensur einbringen.
Also habt ihr im Moment irgendwelche Sachen, die...
Es sind einzelne Anfragen gekommen, ob die Inhalte nicht gesperrt werden können. Also der Zugriff auf die Inhalte über unseren Dienst, das betrifft hauptsächlich Gästebücher, in die irgendwelche unsinnigen oder beleidigenden Nachrichten reingeschrieben wurden von Leuten, die eben über JAP gekommen sind.
Hat denn der Büßow schon angefragt?
Büßow zur Erläuterung Staatssekretär, äh, nicht Staatssekretär, Regierungspräsident Düsseldorf.
Und versucht, ja, Seiten zu sperren.
Glaub ich nicht, aber da müsste ich jetzt meine Kollegen fragen. Ich hab natürlich jetzt die Sperrliste nicht im Kopf. Also es stehen schon ein paar Adressen drin, aber lang ist sie wirklich nicht. Also es kommen im Schnitt vielleicht, ähm, na sagen wir mal, eine halbe pro Monat. Das heißt also sechs im Jahr.
Alle zwei Monate eine sozusagen.
Wir können damit schon fast zum zweiten Thema überleiten. Wir haben uns ja überlegt.
Eine Sekunde, noch eine Frage vom Hörer.
Dirk?
Dirk hat auch keine Fragen mehr. Ich hab nur gelesen zu Messagingdiensten. Ist Instant Messaging von JAP betroffen?
Also wir hatten ursprünglich mal gedacht, auch solche Sachen über JAP verfügbar zu machen. Es hat sich allerdings herausgestellt, dass alles, was so IRC ist und Instant Messaging und so, dass das sehr, sehr gerne auch benutzt wird, um eben auch hier wieder illegale Dinge zu tun. Und haben uns dann entschieden, diesen Dienst, der war nur eine Woche freigeschaltet und das noch nicht mal richtig bekannt unter den Nutzern. Und allein in dieser Woche gab es so viele Anfragen anschließend wegen illegaler Zugriffe, dass wir gesagt haben, das ist zu hoch, das Risiko, da bringen wir uns in Verruf. Und offenbar sind den Nutzer noch nicht so weit, dass sie anonym auch solche Dienste nutzen.
Das war der Soxproxy.
Ok, weil darüber kannst du ja eigentlich alles machen.
Genau.
Ich hab dann zwischendurch auch rausgefunden, warum ein Kopfhörer nicht funktioniert hat.
Und zwar?
Nein, das ist ganz, ganz klasse. Also diese hochprofessionellen Kopfhörer, die wir hier benutzen, die haben 3, 5er Klinkenstecker. Die Anschlüsse sind aber 6, 3 und da ist so ein Adapter, der wird da draufgeschraubt auf die kleine Klinke und der ist abgerutscht. Ja, da wird auch ein Adapter auf die kleine Klinke geschraubt und die rutscht dann ab. Das ist furchtbar, das Leben. Ihr hört das Chaosradio 85, wir reden über Anonymizer, insbesondere über den JAP und da gab es eben die Frage, ob der JAP auch funktioniert mit zum Beispiel ICQ oder IRC. Da hatten wir gesagt, nein, das funktioniert nicht. Da hat dann nochmal der Dirk angerufen und ist ein Missverständnis aufgesessen. Es ist also nicht so, dass der JAP alles Mögliche unterbindet. Also ihr könnt euer ICQ und alles Mögliche weiter benutzen. Ihr braucht nur nicht zu glauben, dass der JAP in der Lage wäre, diese Verbindungen auch zu verschleiden. Der JAP ist nur dazu da, tatsächliches Surfen zu anonymisieren.
So, und was uns natürlich interessieren würde, wäre, wofür würdet ihr denn gerne so einen Anonymizer einsetzen? Also was wäre so eine Anwendung, die euch einfällt, wo ihr so einen Anonymizer brauchen könnt, irgendwie zu Hause oder auf Arbeit oder was auch immer. Das würde uns interessieren. Ruft uns an. Wie lottet die Tonne Nummer halber?
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Ihr habt die Möglichkeit, euch einen Anonymizer runterzuladen, und zwar den JAP unter www.anon-online.de, wenn ihr das tut und ihn nutzt. Warum macht ihr das und was guckt ihr euch an, wenn ihr euch das Ding runtergeladen habt? Wenn ihr hier anruft, um zu sagen, was ihr euch anguckt, ihr müsst ehrliche Antworten geben. Also ihr könnt euer Namen gerne pseudonymisieren oder anonymisieren. Also wir nennen euch dann Anonymous Unus bis Weiß der Geier wohin. Aber erzählts und sag die Wahrheit. 0331 77 97 110. Für welche Seiten würdet ihr einen solchen Anonymizer verwenden? Also wo findet ihr das Ding praktisch? Und den ersten haben wir. Das ist Volker oder wie auch immer du heißt.
Ich habe da mal eine Frage und zwar das Programm, das diese Verfolgung der IP-Adressen ermöglicht hat. Was hat das eigentlich ganz genau gemacht und wo wurde das installiert? Auf dem Rechte des Anwendes oder auf den Profiservern?
Jetzt bin ich da, ja, also es ist so, dass in dem JAP selbst, also der Anwendung, die man runterlädt, überhaupt nichts drin enthalten ist, was diese Überwachung beeinflusst. Da haben wir sozusagen nichts eingebaut, mit dem man, also was überhaupt nötig wäre für diese Rückverfolgung. Man muss sich das nämlich so vorstellen, die Rückverfolgung geschieht folgendermaßen. Im letzten dieser Kette wird ja die IP-Adresse, auf die eben gelockt werden soll, die wir bekommen haben von der Staatsanwaltschaft bzw. vom BKA. Auf diese Adresse wird die aktuelle Verbindung festgehalten, wie bei einer Fangschaltung beim Telefon. Und es wird für eben diese eine Verbindung bis zu dem ersten Mix durchgehend, also die gesamte Kette, versucht alle Teilverbindungen auch festzuhalten. Das heißt, beim allerersten wird genau erkannt, welche Verbindung das eben war. Und dann wird für diese eine Verbindung die IP-Adresse, mit der der JAP sich eingewählt hat, in ein Lockfile geschrieben. Das ist das Prinzip, wie rückverfolgt wird. Im JAP selbst muss dazu gar nichts an Überwachungsfunktionen integriert werden. Es ist also nicht, wie auch so manche eher unseriöse Berichte über unsere Software und über diese Sache jetzt beschrieben haben, keine Spyware oder irgend sowas.
Also auf dem Mix, der auf der Seite des Anwenders stand, auf dem wurde mitgelockt.
Genau. Ich wollte gerne noch eine Sache klären, wenn ich kurz darf. Der Unterschied zwischen dem JAP-Proxy und einem Proxy, der jetzt beim Provider steht, also es ist vielleicht eine Sache, die sich ja ein oder andere jetzt überlegt. Wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft möchte überprüfen, wer auf www.fritz.de zugreift, dann könnten die auch einfach, sagen wir mal, bei T-Online den ganzen Traffic mitsniffen und gucken, wer zu dem Anonymizer-Proxy geht. Und JAP verschlüsselt deswegen. Also es ist nicht nur ein Proxy, sondern auch zwischen dem Anwender und dem Proxy-Server wird schon verschlüsselt.
Genau, das heißt, man sieht auf der Übertragungsstrecke zwischen JAP und eben dem ersten Mix nur verschlüsseltes. Somit kann also auch der Internet Service Provider, mit dem ich mich einwähle, überhaupt nicht erkennen, wohin ich eigentlich surfe.
Die Frage an die Höhrenden lautete, wenn ihr euch das Ding dann installiert habt, also wenn ihr anonym durchs Web es surft, wo surft ihr dann hin? Also für welche Seiten lohnt es sich für euch, anonym dort aufzuschlagen? Und für welche möglicherweise nicht? Hallo Alexander.
Ich benutze die bei der Arbeit. Bisher war mein Anonymizer ein Internetcafé. Warum? Ja, weil mein Arbeitgeber nicht unbedingt mitkriegen soll, ob ich mich für Stellenangebote von einer Konkurrenz interessiere.
Will er das denn mitkriegen? Also besteht da hinreichender Verdacht, dass er da rum schnüffelt?
Genug. Also ich weiß, hab er selbst mit installiert. Also die gucken alles mit bei uns.
Du hast was installiert?
Ja, ich weiß selbst, was ich für Software anschaffe. Ich weiß selbst, was der, also ich kenne die im Keller hier, unsere Informatik-Fruzieste, unsere Netzewerkbetreiber.
Und die schnüffeln nicht nur die Petzen auch, oder was?
Die müssen, die müssen sogar petzen. Die haben Abschussquote, wenn man es ganz büse sagen will.
Verrätst du, wo du arbeitest?
Ach, zu großes Unternehmen, das sag ich lieber jetzt nicht.
Vielleicht eine Bank mit Elektronikanschluss? Eine Bank mit Elektronikanschluss?
Nee, ist keine Bank.
Moment mal, also ich hab das richtig verstanden. Der Chef deines Unternehmens oder wer auch immer da...
Also ich weiß, dass sie im Prinzip, wenn sie sich die ganze Masse von Informationen von allen Mitarbeitern holen würden, die quasi jede Internetverbindung, die wir aufbauen, feststellen können und auch zuordnen können. Weil wir uns in die Computer einloggen müssen. Wir sind da mit Karte und einem Pippa-Po.
Das betrifft vermutlich auch E-Mail, oder?
Genau, naja, die haben ja auch Angst, dass wir was wegschicken, was nicht weggeschickt werden darf, ist natürlich klar.
Ja, das ist ja bei Unternehmen unterschiedlich gehandhabt, ob die sozusagen sagen, das ist ein betrieblicher Internetanschluss und deswegen haben sie damit auch das Recht...
Das Geld ist denen nicht so wichtig, entscheidet, was drin ist.
Jaja, klar, aber deswegen, zusammen mit der Argumentation, es handele sich um einen betrieblichen Internetanschluss, gilt nämlich nicht mehr das, was man mal Fernmeldegeheimnis genannt hat und das wäre sozusagen die Privatsphäre bei der E-Mail zumindest als rechtliches Kostum.
Nee, die können sich ja auch auf den Arbeitsvertrag berufen.
Jaja, okay, und da heißt es explizit...
Wenn ich am Dienst bin, was ich da tue, das müssen die halt wissen. Also ich kann ja auch nicht mit der Frankiermaschine Briefe verschicken.
Würde dein Arbeitgeber denn gestatten, dass du deine Mails verschlüsselst?
Das macht er ja, das lässt er ja zu.
Ach, das lässt er zu?
Aber nur intern.
Er kann ja nicht kontrollieren, welche Software bei mir auf dem Rechner läuft. Ja, nicht nur das. Wir haben auch Linux hier, das ist kein Ding. Oder irgendwelche Unix-Client hier, das ist kein Ding hier.
Ja, ne, tausend Dank. Das ist glaube ich ein wichtiger...
Da war ich beim Internetcafé und da ist für mich... Die einzige Frage, die ich habe, ob man diesen Service, dieses Ding auch rekursiv benutzen kann, also mich erst da anonymisieren lassen und dann nochmal einloggen. Und dann beispielsweise Kinderpornos angucke, ob das System denn...
Also was du machen könntest, du könntest, wenn du die JAP-Software einsetzt, einfach ein Proxy davor schalten, die Software erlaubt ist.
Was? Bist du noch da, Alexander? Was ist denn das? Ich werde dir überwacht, sag ich dir. Nee, Matthias, ist das so eine Telefonanlage immer wieder dir?
Das weiß ich nicht. Da ich ja gerade gegenüber stehe, aber...
was machst du da eigentlich für Verrenkungen, mein Gott?
Ich mach ja Ordnung.
Entsetzlich, es ist entsetzlich. Gut, und jetzt ist es auch halb.
Wenn Fritz in Schallottenburg, dann 100 2, 6.
Es ist, nee, wenig Wetteränderung, sowas. Es ist heiter bis wolkig, überwiegend trocken bei Höchstwerten um 22 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkos.
Die Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt gegen einen Chefarzt wegen des Verdachts auf Körperverletzungen mindestens 30 Fällen, das berichtete Tagesspiegel, der Berliner Arzt soll regelmäßig zu spät im Operationssaal erschienen sein, dadurch soll er die Narkose der Patienten unnötig verlängert haben. Die Bundeswehr soll ihren Afghanistan-Einsatz über Kabul hinaus ausdehnen, mehr als 250 Soldaten sollen noch in diesem Jahr zusätzlich in die nordafghanische Stadt Kunduz verlegt werden. Das hat das Sicherheitskabinett in Berlin beschlossen, Voraussetzung ist allerdings, dass die UNO die Erweiterung des Mandats billigt. Auf die Berliner Humboldt-Universität gibt es einen Ansturm von Studienanwärtern. Mehr als vier Bewerber kommen auf einen Studienplatz, sagte ein HU-Sprecher. Rund 250.300 Interessenten haben sich für das erste Fachsemester beworben. Zum Sport. In der Champions League Qualifikation unterlag Borussia Dortmund dem FC Brügge mit einem 2 zu 4 im Elfmeterschießen. Damit darf Borussia Dortmund lediglich im UI Cup noch international mitkicken. Und in einem Nachholspiel der ersten Fußball-Bundesliga trennten sich am Abend Hannover 96 und Hansa Rostock mit 3 zu 3. Unentschieden. Verkehrsmeldungen haben wir keine. Gute Fahrt.
Hier ist die Perle.
Ich wünsch mit.
China Aguilera. Deutschland sucht den Superstar.
Ein schönes Lied von Mennewolf.
Einfach nur anrufen, wünschen und grüßen.
031 70 97 130. Musikwunsch-Erfüllungsradiosendung mit Grüßen. Immer Montag bis Freitag. Ab 19 Uhr und im Radio.
Chaosradio 85 ist hier, wir reden über Anonymizer und insbesondere den JAP. Den könnt ihr euch runterladen und installieren und auch vorher die FAQ lesen zum Beispiel, dann habt ihr nicht so viele Fragen hinterher unter www.anon-online.de und eine Frage an euch haben wir auch.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Eine Anonymizer dient dazu zu verschleiern, wo ihr hin surft. Angenommen, ihr benutzt eine Anonymizer. Wo surft ihr denn so hin, dass ihr denkt, dass es verschleierungswürdig wäre? Also wenn ihr einen JAP laufen habt, welche Seiten guckt ihr euch an? Wir haben eben schon mal gehört, Stellenangebote vom, also Konkurrenzstellenangebote, vom Firmenarbeitsplatz aus. Das ist zum Beispiel eine ganz praktische Adresse, die mit einem Anonymizer anzusurfen wäre. Welche anderen Adressen es sein könnten, würden wir ganz gerne von euch hören. Unter 0331, 70, 97, 110. Hier geht gerade gar nichts mehr, das ist auch super.
Aber dein Kopfhörer geht noch, oder?
Ich werd irre, ey, ich werd irre. Bernd?
Ja, hallo?
Hey, hallo Bernd.
Ja, hallo schön. Ich hätte da mal gern zwei Fragen.
Fragen, auch gut.
Ja, zum einen, warum funktioniert der JAP nicht bei zum Beispiel CASA? Also wäre es rein technisch möglich oder?
Das hatten wir schon geklärt. Technisch möglich ist es, aber er funktioniert nicht, weil mit CASA eben auch recht häufig, wie soll man es nennen, Gesetze gebrochen bzw. gebeugt werden.
Naja, aber der technische Grund ist ja, dass dieser Anonymizer hier nur für Web ist.
Ja, aber technisch möglich wäre es, also um die Frage zu sagen.
Ja, Moment, Moment.
Also peer-to-peer funktioniert so, dass du deine IP bekannt gibst, damit Leute von dir deine Platte leer lossen können. Das ist ja genau die Idee, dass du auch uploadest. Und wenn du durch einen Anonymizer gehst, dann sieht er gegenüber nicht deine IP, sondern die vom Anonymizer. Daher kann peer-to-peer über Anonymizer nicht funktionieren.
Also rein möglich, rein...
Moment mal eben, haben wir doch gehört, dass es technisch möglich wäre, aber ausprogrammiert ist, Fefe.
Ja, ich sag ja, es wäre technisch...
Du hast gesagt, das kann nicht funktionieren, doch es kann.
Nein, also peer-to-peer kann nicht funktionieren. Du kannst prinzipiell so was wie ICQ darüber machen. Aber peer-to-peer heißt gerade, dass du dich direkt zu dem Gegenüber verbindest und ihr gegenseitig Daten austauscht.
Also peer-to-peer ist doch, wenn ich das mal zitieren darf, was ich auf einer Veranstaltung neulich gelernt habe, ist das Prinzip, wenn Kühe auf einmal Gras scheißen. Moment, das geht ja darum, dass man da Ressourcen share. Ja, oder wie du es auch immer nennst, hier geht es aber bei diesem Dienstjahr rein um das klassische Modell, es gibt irgendwo einen Server, von dem kann man Internetinhalte abrufen und man möchte eben nicht seine Absenderadresse hinterlassen. Was du mit File Sharing bzw. Peer-to-Peer machst, ist ja was ganz anderes, nämlich eben aus dem klassischen Modell, das hier gibt es einen Sender und da gibt es mehrere Empfänger und der Sender soll nicht wissen, wer die Empfänger sind, auszubrechen und dich ja ins Austausch von Dateien zu begeben. Und das ist ja was ganz anderes und dazu ist zumindest dieser Dienst hier nicht konstruiert, auch wenn man das technisch natürlich auch für Filesharing und irgendwie Peer-to-Peer und den ganzen wie gesagt Gras-Scheißen in Kuhhaufen installieren könnte.
Also es wäre zwar machbar, aber dieses Programm bietet es nicht an. Richtig. Und meine Frage, und zwar ist ja auch eine weit verbreitete Sache, und zwar einen Pub zu nutzen, auf dem man Dateien ablehnt, dass dort die IP-Adresse nicht mitgelockt werden könnte, wäre dies möglich?
Einen was zu nutzen?
Einen Pub, also man...
Das ist eine englische Kneipe, die um halb 12 zu macht.
Ja, wäre auch eine Möglichkeit, ist schon okay. Aber ich denke, ihr wisst, was ich meine. Also sprich, ich scanne jetzt diverse Server ab und...
Du meinst einen Web-Server, auf dem ein Ordner, der Pub heißt, liegt, in dem es Dateien gibt, die du dir holen möchtest?
Naja, wo ich eventuell auch was ablege und auch für andere Leute. Also sprich, wenn ich mich dort einlogge, dort eventuell Dateien ablege, natürlich völlig legale Dateien, und die sich dann jemand runterladen kann, wenn ich eben halt nicht online bin. Ja, ob dies möglich wäre, dort was abzulegen, ohne, also ob es überhaupt möglich wäre, ohne dass meine IP mitgeloggt wird.
Also deine IP wird nicht mitgeloggt, wenn du die Inhalte aufrufst, und es wird auch nicht die IP mitgeloggt, wenn du versuchst, Inhalte dort abzulegen. Allerdings ist im JAP eine Sperre eingebaut, die verhindert, dass du riesengroße Daten ins Netz laden kannst. Es ist eine Software, die zum Abrufen gedacht ist. Diese Sperre, die wir da eingebaut haben, ist deshalb da, weil wir eben verhindern wollen, dass zum Beispiel irgendwelche Verrückte anfangen, zum Beispiel illegale Inhalte darüber zu verbreiten. Es ist also auch wieder eine Sicherheitsfunktion insofern, die verhindert, dass der Missbrauch besonders groß wird. Du kannst darüber natürlich E-Mails versenden, über GMX oder andere Web-Interfaces. Da musst du ja auch Daten gewissermaßen hochladen auf den Surfer, bevor du sie wegschicken kannst. Und genau das gleiche kannst du natürlich mit deinen Pubs auch machen.
Ja, und jetzt, wie groß dürften die Dateien denn sein?
Das kann ich dir im Moment nicht sagen. Dann müssten wir schnell unseren Entwickler anrufen, aber der liegt bestimmt schon im Bett. Es kann auch sein, er sitzt am Rechner. Müssen wir mal gucken. Also vermutlich irgendwas in der Größenordnung von so 20, 25 Kilobyte. Es könnten auch etwas mehr sein.
Okay, meine Fragen sind beantwortet.
Wofür würdest du den benutzen? Na ja, er hat doch gerade gesagt, wofür ich ihn benutzen würde.
Entschuldigung.
Sebastian? Sebastian? Ja, du bist dran. Sprich mal ein bisschen lauter bitte.
Ja, also die technische Frage nach dem Aussuchen der Betreiber der Mixe, nach welchen Kriterien sucht ihr diese Betreiber aus, dass sie dann halt auch zuverlässig sind? Und vielleicht gleich anschließend das hypothetische Beispiel, es könnten sich ja beispielsweise ein Stromann des BKA und diverse andere Leute rund um die Welt absprechen, dass sie sich bei euch ebenfalls melden und einen Mix betreiben wollen und sozusagen eine eigene Kaskade bilden und damit wäre ja dann dieses Verschlüsselungs- und Sicherheitssystem des JAPs dann wieder ausgehebelt, weil der erste wüsste ja vom letzten und die dazwischen kennen sich auch und damit könnte man ja im Grunde dann die Daten wieder entschlüsseln und auch zu den einzelnen Benutzern zuordnen. Würde das gehen?
Genau, also wenn alle in einer Kaskade zusammenarbeiten, um eben zu enttarnen, dann hast du völlig recht, dann wäre das tatsächlich möglich. Es ist momentan so, wir befinden uns ja noch in dieser Forschungsphase und Entwicklungsphase, dass wir alle, die den Mix betreiben wollen, ja sagen wir mal ein bisschen angucken, also gucken halt auf deren Webseiten. Aber im Prinzip kann jeder, der die entsprechende Bandbreite hat und auch das technische Vermögen sowas zu betreiben, kann sich bei uns melden und hat gute Chancen, Mixbetreiber zu werden. Die spätere Phase, wenn die Software dann fertig entwickelt ist und vielleicht auch mal richtig eingesetzt wird von zum Beispiel irgendwie einer Betreibergesellschaft oder vielleicht auch sich sozusagen frei und anarchisch dann einfach Mixe finden, die Phase, die ist völlig ungeklärt. Wir arbeiten momentan daran, dass dieser Informationsdienst, über den man überhaupt erfährt, welche Kaskaden eigentlich da sind, der könnte nämlich genauso angreifen, erst mal ein verteiltes System wird. Es gibt momentan einen einzigen, der wird von uns betrieben und es soll zukünftig viele unabhängige solche Infoservices geben und die können dann eben, wenn beispielsweise einer betrügt oder so, sich auch gegenseitig kontrollieren. Das ist der erste Schritt und der nächste Schritt wäre dann, dass man irgend sowas bräuchte wie ein Reglement, wie man eigentlich neue Mixbetreiber hinzunimmt. Es ist im aktuellen Zustand so, dass jeder Mixbetreiber sich verpflichten muss in einer sogenannten Selbstverpflichtungserklärung, die kann man auch auf unserer Webseite angucken. In der steht eben drin, dass er keine Daten sammelt und Leute nicht beobachtet. Ich muss dazu sagen, dass diese Selbstverpflichtungserklärung noch in dieser Vor-BKA-Beschluss-Ära geschrieben wurde und natürlich aus heutiger Sicht nicht mehr ganz aktuell ist. Auch hier arbeiten wir momentan daran, dass diese Selbstverpflichtungserklärungen geändert werden. Dann müssen sich natürlich alle Mixbetreiber, wenn sie das wollen, und in der Lage dazu sind, auf die neuen gewissermaßen Konditionen dann auch committen.
Selbstverpflichtungen in Deutschland sind aber nicht unbedingt das, was man als glaubwürdig bezeichnen kann, oder? Ich meine, die Industrie macht das seit Jahren und es kommt nichts mehr hoch.
Die FDP macht das seit Jahren.
Dosenpfand, sag ich nur.
Es gibt im Moment keine andere rechtliche Handhabe. Man könnte natürlich einen echten Vertrag schließen, allerdings unter juristischen Gesichtspunkten ist die Selbstverpflichtungserklärung auch nichts anderes als ein Vertrag. Es wäre denkbar, dass man zum Beispiel auch den Benutzern die freie Auswahl gibt, welche Mixer sie eigentlich benutzen wollen. Das wird viel diskutiert und es wird sehr häufig auch von unseren Benutzern vorgeschlagen. Es gibt allerdings etliche wissenschaftliche Papiere, in denen relativ gut auch für die Allgemeinheit beschrieben steht, dass das die Anonymität der Benutzer eher senken würde. Also du musst dir einfach folgendes vorstellen. Alle Benutzer in einer Kaskade, die die gleiche Reihenfolge dieser Mixer benutzen, die sind zusammen anonymen. Wenn du jetzt allein, sagen wir, drei Mixer so konfigurieren kannst, dass sie in beliebiger Reihenfolge von jedem Benutzer zusammengeklickt werden können, dann kannst du dir die Wahrscheinlichkeit ausrechnen, wie viel Benutzer sozusagen die gleiche Kaskade zusammenklicken. Nehmen wir an, das ist gleich verteilt. Und du wirst einfach feststellen, dass die Anzahl derer, die gemeinsam anonym sind, bei gleicher Verkehrslast viel, viel geringer ist. Sodass also mit steigender Anzahl von Mixen, die du zusammenklickst, eben deine Anonymität noch nicht mal wirklich steigt, weil einfach die Benutzerzahl dann zu gering ist. Sodass das also nicht besonders sinnvoll ist, um nur einmal ein Argument zu bringen, warum man es so nicht machen sollte. Wer es genauer wissen will, kann das alles in den wissenschaftlichen Papieren nachlesen. Auch hier einfach eine E-Mail schicken an unseren Support und dann bekommt man die entsprechenden Links im Internet.
Ich muss mehr GEZ-Gebühren zahlen.
Was möchtest du?
Ich muss noch mehr GEZ-Gebühren zahlen, fällt mir gerade auf.
Ja, das solltest du tun, ja. Weißt du was, Pefe, wir melden dich jetzt einfach mal online an. Du hast es ja bestimmt vergessen, ne?
Nee, stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Chaosradio 85 ist hier. Wir sprachen die ganze Zeit über Anonymizer. Und natürlich wollten wir wissen, was denn sich anonym anzugucken lohnt. Und eine Sache, die sich sicherlich an anonymen anzugucken lohnt, sind Seiten mit Inhalten, die vielleicht nicht systemstabilisierend sind.
Ja, wenn man sich das Internet so anguckt, früher, also ganz früher, als das Internet so aufkam, die Mailbox-Netze aufkam, da haben wir immer davon geredet, naja, also dann hat endlich jeder die Chance zu publizieren, dann können wir endlich mal Inhalte publizieren, die nicht mit den Mainstream-Medien zu tun haben. Und es hat erstaunlicherweise doch eine ganze Weile gedauert, bis tatsächlich Inhalte, die qualitativ hochwertig sind und trotzdem nicht mit den Mainstream-Medien zu tun haben, in die Netze gekommen sind. Eigentlich kann ich schon so sagen, erst in den letzten anderthalb Jahren ist da tatsächlich eine Szene entstanden, wo Leute angefangen haben, Inhalte zu produzieren, die wirklich istwürdig sind, auch wahrgenommen zu werden.
Du meinst Weblogs?
Weblogs ist zum Beispiel ein Trend, der sicherlich sehr lebendig und sehr interessant ist.
Na, Weblogs ist eher ein Aufsatz. Also Weblogs sind hervorragend dafür, die eine wirklich sehr obskure Zeit bekannt zu machen, wenn die eine coole Story bringen.
Außerdem finde ich das ein bisschen überheblich, wenn du sagst, erst seit anderthalb Jahren, also es ist doch einfach mal so.
Ich rede vom Massentrend an. Ich sage nicht, dass es das nicht gab, aber es ist jetzt tatsächlich erst ein Trend, der so in den letzten anderthalb Jahren entstanden ist, dass plötzlich viele, viele interessante Sites gibt, wo Leute tatsächlich anfangen zu sagen, okay, ich will dieses Internet nicht nur als großen Trichter in meinen Hirn haben, wo irgendwie mir die ganze Scheiße reinkommt, sondern ich möchte tatsächlich anfangen, meine Meinung, meine Recherchen, meine Dinge da rein zu tun.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, dass es auch saubere Recherchen gibt, die undogmatisch daherkommen, das ist noch gar nicht so lange.
Genau.
Also das gibt es vielleicht ja eineinhalb Jahre.
Viele von den Sachen sind halt nur nicht besonders systemstabilisierend, weil die systemstabilisierenden Sachen finden sich halt in Mainstream-Media naturgemäß. Wir wollen gerne jetzt mit einem Gast reden, per Telefon. Christopher Albrighton. Christoph, I'm just doing the introduction in German, then I'm coming to questions.
I'm sorry?
Christoph hat die Site Back to Iraq gemacht. Da ging es darum, unabhängige Berichterstattung sozusagen vom Anfang des letzten Irakkrieges aus dem Irak zu machen, also nicht im Rahmen von CNN oder anderen Mainstream-Medien. Und wir können hier gleich mal fragen, wie ihr das gemacht habt. Christoph, you did the Back to Iraq-Site, for what reason precisely?
Well, I started out in October of last year as a way of raising money to go back to Iraq, because I had a strong hunch that the United States would be going to war sometime in 2003. I actually thought it would probably be in the fall of 2002, but I was wrong and they pushed it back further. And the reason I did that is because I felt that it was important to get an independent eye, you know, a set of eyes in there to see what was going on and to report back as honestly as possible without any kind of influence from either corporate pressure or advertising pressure or being embedded with the US military or anything like that. I raised money from my readers, ultimately about 14,000 American dollars. There was no one else that I was reporting for.
What kind of equipment did you use during your time in Iraq?
You have a fairly professional journalistic background, so you worked for a lot of mainstream media. Was ist einer der Reasons, warum du es gefällt hast, dass es mehr independent reporting gibt?
Well, die AP ist eine unik Institution in Journalismus, in dem es ein Not-for-profit ist und es keine Advertising hat. Also muss die AP aus dieser Beweise ausgeführt werden. Alles andere ist commercial und for-profit, generell gesagt. Aber ich bin da hin, weil ich dachte, dass eine einzelne Person oder vielleicht ein kleiner Team, hypothetisch gesagt, aber eine einzelne Person wäre viel mehr nimmel, wäre viel einfacher, um herumzukommen. Es war eine gute Storyidee, und es war nicht zu gefährlich.
Was hast du mit dem Mainstream-Media in diesem Kampf erlebt, das, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, mit US-Armien in diesem verbundenen Team-Stuff?
Ich war im Norden, in der Irakischen Kurdistan-Region. Aber sie hatten auch mehr Freiheit. Andere würden sagen, dass sie nationalistisch waren als andere Medien, die ich gefunden habe. Ich denke, und ich spreche jetzt von amerikanischen Medien. Und ich denke, dass die Broadcastmedien, die amerikanischen Medien, die ich in der Tat gesehen habe, eine sehr unformale Arbeit haben.
Es war sehr wie ein Sport-Event.
Ich hatte eine Öffentlichkeit eröffnet, in den Monaten, die sich auf die Waffe führen. Ich habe das im Oktober begonnen. Das war mein zweiter Reise in den Irak. Sie haben mich vertraut. Du schreibst ehrlich und trüfflich. All das, was du tun kannst, ist, so fair zu sein wie möglich.
Hatte du das Gefühl, dass das Teil der Erleichterung ein bisschen in den Weg zu gehen, dein Ziel des Reportages, oder hattest du das Gefühl, das ist ein Teil der Geschichte, das ist das, wofür ich hier war?
Ich hätte gerne mehr Fokus auf mich und mehr auf die Geschichte aufnehmen können, aber ich weiß auch, dass die Leute, die es liest, persönlich in das, was ich versuchte, investiert haben. Die Leute begannen wirklich, mich und meine Freundin zu beachten, die ich persönlich mit reisen durfte. Es war definitiv ein Aspekt des Marketing, in Bezug auf die Beratung der Reaktion, die.
Hat der Mainstream Media in irgendeinem Reaktor gewusst?
Als ich den Krieg aufgetreten habe, hatte ich 23.000 Leute pro Tag auf der Webseite und ich hatte fast 600.000 Leute, die auf der Webseite nach Januar 2017 besuchen, als ich die Kontinuose von den Rekorden behalten habe. Aber ich denke nicht, dass das wirklich genug war, um eine Geschichte in den Mainstream-Media zu bewegen. Ich denke, es ist interessant, was nächstes kommt.
Hattest du einen Bascamp oder eine Homebase, oder jemanden, der dir ein paar Leaks schicken könnte?
Ich konnte in der ganzen Welt etwas von dem, was da passiert ist, und nicht nur in meiner kleinen Bubbel. Er würde mir Dinge e-Mailen und mir sagen, was da passiert ist, und ich würde mir hier bemerken.
Was denkt ihr über die Zukunft? Ist das ein Art Method für Journalismus, das sich selbst erstaunen wird, oder ist das nur möglich in Krisenmode?
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, ich versuche, eine neue Art zu arbeiten, mit einigen Freunden und Kollegen. Und dann würden sie diese Art von Life-Stories von Indonesien, oder von Kongo oder Südamerika oder so weiter.
Auch mit dem Method von direktem Feedback zu den Komponisten?
Denn es ist keine Einwegkommunikation von der Ederneinheit, dem Berater, dem Reader mehr. Es ist nun eine Gespräche zwischen der Reiterin und dem Berater.
Ich denke, das wäre die wichtige Sache, dass kein Anonymus-Ederne die Art von Storys, die gemacht werden, aber dass man sich die Hände geben kann und sagt, okay.
Und wenn jemand mir eine dumme Idee gibt, dann fange ich nicht an, weil ein Reiter es mir gegeben hat. Und ich dachte, okay, ich habe etwas auf der Turkmen-Front gemacht, die ist ein kleiner... Wie bekannt ist die Turkmen-Front in Deutschland?
Für mich ist es ziemlich bekannt, aber ich bin ein Journalist. Turkmenistan?
Und ich habe es herausgefunden, na klar, schau mal rein. Es war eine sehr interessante Geschichte, ich habe mit einem der Presidenzen eines der drei Hauptparteien im Irak, Kurdistan, in einer sehr interessanten Interview geredet, die über die Ethnischen Tensions in Kyrgyzstan, in Erbil und in Sulaimaniya geredet haben. Die Turkmen-Story?
Nein, die ganze Idee, nur ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr lang in ein desertes Land zu gehen, ohne eigentlich Geld zu verdienen.
Ich würde das in einer Minute machen. Ich bin noch immer Geld verdienen, und ich versuche noch, dort zurückzukommen, um die Ökonomie und dieses Guerrilla-Wars zu schreiben. Wenn jemand will, mich weiter zu donieren, und mich zurückzudrücken, ich war da ein Monat lang, ich würde gerne zwei bis drei Monate zurückkommen.
Wo können wir die Donationen geben?
Ihr könnt auf der Webseite www.back2irak.com gehen, und dort gibt es eine Donation-Signale, die mit PayPal ausgeliefert wird, die ich glaube, in Deutschland gibt es. Ich würde mein eigenes Satellit-Phone kaufen, weil ich es letztes Mal rentierte. Ich würde mein eigenes Satellit-Phone kaufen, aber 100.000 Dollar...
Ein Freund meines hat einen von einem Freund meines und einem Mann gestohlen.
Ich könnte es für dich finden. Ich brauche keine anderen Equipment. Denn das Ziel ist es, unabhängig zu bleiben. Ich möchte viele Schauspieler, die kleine Anzahl geben, als sich ein Schauspieler, eine große Anzahl geben. Denn so hat niemand eine große. Ich würde lieber 5.000, 5 Dollar-Donationen haben, als ein 25.000 Dollar-Donation.
Und wenn ihr euch das Ganze nochmal angucken wollt, jetzt mal auf deutsche www.backtoirak.com Berichterstattung und zwar unabhängige Berichterstattung über den Irak, aus dem Irak, während des Irak-Kriegs. Bitte?
Irak mit Kuh geschrieben, ist ein Ami.
Ja, dankeschön. Über den Irak-Krieg und aus dem Irak vor allen Dingen, und das von einem professionellen Journalisten, der möglichst wenig Dogmen in seine Arbeit verarbeitet. Vier Minuten nach Mitternacht. Chaosradio 85, wir sprachen den ganzen Abend über Anonymizer. Jetzt gerade haben wir mit jemandem gesprochen, der eine alternative Informationsquelle bietet, denn alternative Informationsquellen könnten eine Adresse sein, die per Anonymizer angesurft werden wollen, weil vielleicht ihr irgendwo arbeitet, oder irgendwo sitzt, wo niemand mitkriegen soll. Das hier euch aus etwas anderen Quellen, also aus etwas anderem als den Mainstream-Medien informiert. Wir lehnen uns jetzt ein paar Minuten zurück und verdauen, was wir gerade alles auf Englisch gehört haben, und melden uns wieder nach der Musik. Chaosradio 85, immer noch ein bisschen Musik gehört, um uns vorzubereiten auf quasi den Nachrichtenticker, den der Kollege Müller Magun an dieser Stelle zum Besten geben möchte. Möchtest du am Anfang schon einen Geräusch? Oh, der Trommelwirbel, warte mal. Der Trommelwirbel.
Der Chaosradio!
Ich glaube, du hast gerade unsere Glaubwürdigkeit in den Verbruch gebracht.
Ja, es ist ja auch, wenn wir Roland Koch zum Beispiel glauben dürfen, nicht wichtig die Wahrheit zu sagen, sondern nur glaubwürdig zu sein.
Oh, jetzt wo du es sagst.
Und da hast du noch einen.
Der Rechnungshof der USA hat bei einer Buchberufung für das Jahr 2000 gefunden. Dass im Verteidigungsministerium 1, 1 Milliarden US-Dollar, ja im Moment Millionen, Ach du Hilfe, nicht Milliarden, verschwunden sind. Das nennt sich dann Unsupported Account Entries. Eine Buchberufung beim HOD, das ist das Housing and Urban Development, fand heraus, dass alleine während der Dauer der Buchberufung zu den bereits vermissten 17, 6 Milliarden Dollar noch Anpassungen für weitere 59, 6 Milliarden Dollar in die Bücher aufgenommen wurden. Ja, das kann ich eh nicht lesen. Schade.
Vielleicht bereitest du dich da nochmal erneut noch vor?
Ja Mensch, du hattest ja doch noch weiter.
Ja, mach doch mal den Trommelwirbel.
Der Trommelwirbel, jetzt mach du mal lieber da dein Gekränkchen.
Das ist hier irgendwie in vier Punkten ausgedruckt.
So und wir versuchen es jetzt noch mal, also quasi der Chaosradio Nachrichtenticker mit Andi Müller-Magun!
Vor dem Hamburger Amtsgericht hat am Mittwoch der Prozess gegen drei Polizisten aus Thüringen begonnen, die bei einem Großeinsatz gegen Demonstranten in der Hansestadt im vergangenen November zwei im Zivil gekleidete Kollegen aus Schleswig-Holstein dienstunfähig geprübelt haben sollten. Die Staatsanwaltschaft warf den Beamten im Alter von 23, 20 und 30 Jahren vor vorsätzlich und ohne ersichtlichen Grund mit ihren Schlagslöten wiederholt auf Kopf, Arme und Beine der Zivilpolizisten eingeschlagen zu haben. Die Geschädigten erlitten Prellungen, sie waren eine Woche lang krank geschrieben. Die Angeklagten stritten die Vorwürfe jedoch ab. Das sechs Monate alte Department of Homeland Security in den USA hat bisher etwa 40 Prozent seiner 160.000 Angestellten als Watchers, also als Beobachter an Flughäfen zu einem durchschnittlichen Jahresgehalt zu 29.000 Dollar angestellt, hat aber auch 324 Beerdigungsdirektoren, das kann doch nicht wirklich hier stehen, doch hier steht wirklich Beerdigungsdirektoren, 128 Pharmazeuten, 25 Anthropologen und 41 Fingerabdruckspezialisten sowie 30, was ist das denn hier?
Prediger.
Prediger, also 30 Prediger haben die auch noch angestellt.
Vielleicht willst du das vorlesen, Frank?
Ja, aber das versteht ja keiner, also auf gut Deutsch die Amerikaner haben sozusagen unter dem Begriff der Homeland Security eine ABM-Maßnahme eingeführt, wo sie halt Beerdigungsdirektoren, Pharmazeuten, Prediger und man ist das einschaffen. Kann ich mal diesen Trommelwirbel bekommen? US-Piloten werden jetzt mit dem Umgang mit Pistolen trainiert, sollen Waffen im Cockpit dabei haben. Deckt sich übrigens mit Meldungen aus Flugzeugen wie aus der L-ALWUS, wo es im oberen, also im ersten Stock sozusagen keine First Class gibt, sondern da sitzen dann Soldaten, die schwer bewaffnet sozusagen schussfähig, für den Fall, dass jemand versucht, das Flugzeug zu entführen, bereit sitzen. Und die Flugzeugmantel, also die Umantelung der Flugzeuge selbst, ist auch dagegen gehärtet, dass etwaige, bei Schießereien, nicht etwa ein Loch in die Flugzeugaußenwand hinein gerät und dann ein Druckabfall entsteht, sondern...
Bauen die Israelis Flugzeuge aus Blei?
Na ja, die lassen sich einfach mal ganz normale Flugzeuge noch mal zusätzlich verhärten, damit die da in aller Ruhe drinnen rumballern können. Das Umweltministerium hat auf Geheiz des Weißen Hauses über die Gefährlichkeit der Gesundheitsrisiken durch den Staub des World Trade Centers. Felix, ihr fehlt der Rest des Satzes.
Na ja, dann machen wir ein bisschen Musik, da können wir wenigstens.
Ja.
All diese Nachrichten, die Andi gerade vorgelesen hat, stammen natürlich nicht aus den Mainstream-Medien. Wir haben alle so ein paar Sites, die wir gelenklich angucken und die halt nicht unbedingt spiegeln, die sonstige Mainstream-Medien sind, von denen wir versuchen, so ein paar Informationen zu beziehen. Einige davon sind halt kostenpflichtig, manche sind halt auch einfach noch so ein bisschen durchgedreht, wieder andere landen auch ganz schnell mal in der Verschwörerecke. Was uns interessieren würde, ist, was für alternative Nachrichtenquellen benutzt ihr denn? Es gibt halt so, die halt jeder kennt, so was irgendwie, so was wie Indymedia oder sowas, aber eigentlich für mich eher sowas wie ein Heiseforum für irgendwie die Links-Intellektuellen ist. Aber es gibt da sicherlich auch noch jede Menge Sites, die uns zum Beispiel nicht bekannt sind, die uns auch interessieren würden, wo es halt Nachrichten gibt, die nicht überall erscheinen.
Da würde uns mal interessieren, was ihr da so benutzt, ruft uns doch einfach an unter 0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Surftipps abliefern jetzt im Chaosradio. Welche alternativen Nachrichtenquellen sollten wir uns angucken und sollte sich jeder angucken, der diese Sendung hört und vielleicht auch nicht hört, auf dass es ihm weiter erzählt wird. 0331 70 97 110.
Ja, also diese Sendung war nicht nur, also der zweite Teil der Sendung war nicht nur gedacht, um euch zu fragen, was ihr für coole Sites kennt, sondern im Grunde sind wir auch mit dem Anspruch, heute hier euch zu motivieren, selbst solche Sites rauszusuchen. Denn das ist nicht wie bei Spiegel und, weiß ich, Süddeutsche, dass man da eben zwei, drei URLs hat und da geht man halt alle paar Tage gucken und da stehen dann eben die Nachrichten, sondern es ist schon so, dass man da eher so eine Liste von 20, 30 Sites hat, die mehr oder weniger häufig aktualisiert werden. Und vor allem ist es durchaus so, dass man sich durch eine Flut von Meldungen tatsächlich durcharbeiten muss, von denen eben, sagen wir mal, wenn es hochkommt, 20, 30 Prozent tatsächlich qualitativ wertvoll sind und auch interessant sind und auch vertrauenswürdig sind. Also ich habe hier auch ein Beispiel für eine besonders krasse Desinformationszeit da und es gibt halt auch so Verschwörungstheoretiker, die wirklich völlig abgefahrene Sachen, Zusammenhänge da herstellen. Also das ist ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man nicht zu spiegel.de surft zum Beispiel, weil viele Leute würden beim Spiegel sagen, okay das sind erfahrene Journalisten und so, die übelsten Enden werden von denen rausgefehlt hat. Das gibt es halt nicht, wenn man sich völlig unabhängig informiert.
Ja, aber wie willst du dann feststellen, ob jemand glaubwürdig ist oder nicht?
Na das ist ein Gefühl, was man entwickeln muss. Also ich habe hier diese Liste, die Andi hier vorgelesen hat, das ist im Grunde eine Liste von Sachen, die in den letzten drei, vier Tagen so über, wir haben im CCC eine Meldingliste, so unter paar Puppets, wo wir uns sowas halt zuschinken. Und ich würde auch allen empfehlen, die heute zuhören und an alternativen Nachrichten interessiert sind, sich auch solche Meldinglisten aufzumachen oder einen Weblog und das mit Freunden zu sharen. Denn im Grunde ist es nicht sinnvoll, dass jeder komplett alle Sites durchgeht, sondern es geht eben darum, dass jeder guckt, so ein paar Sites, die ihm interessant erscheinen, die sich mit Sachen beschäftigen, die ihnen interessieren, die guckt er durch und entwickelt dann eben auch ein Gefühl dafür, was glaubwürdig ist oder was nicht. Aber man hat nie Schutz davor, dass irgendein Site komplett Bullshit schreibt, um das mal ganz brutal zu sagen. Das kann passieren, das passiert auch relativ häufig.
Also die Kunst besteht halt, als sich darin für sich selbst zu denken. Man übernimmt halt einen Teil des Prozesses, den man sonst an die professionellen Journalisten delegiert, nämlich die Abschätzung von dem, was jetzt als Wahrheit oder zumindest als plausibel gelten kann, die muss man halt im Zweifel selber tun. Und es gibt halt Sites, die werden halt auch einfach mehr oder minder offen von irgendwelchen Geheimdiensten betrieben, die da halt ihre eigenen Sachen publizieren wollen. Also ein klassisches Beispiel dafür ist zum Beispiel debka.com. Das ist halt eine israelische Site, die sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass sie häufig Sachen, dass es häufig gelegentlich Sachen hat vor allen anderen, die sich dann doch als wahr herausstellen, aber dass sie häufig genug Haber auch einfach Desinformationen verbreiten, die halt irgendwie gerade im Interesse der Israelis sind. So da muss man halt einfach so ein bisschen abwägen und so ein bisschen gucken, gibt es die Nachrichten noch woanders, wie plausibel ist das, passt das eigentlich mit dem zusammen, was man sonst noch so weiß? Andere Möglichkeiten...
Nenn noch mal ein Beispiel, wir haben heute eine schöne Story gehabt in den letzten Tagen von DEPKAR, hier die mit den SIG Insights im Irak.
Ja genau, also zum Beispiel eine der Stories, die gerade kamen auf DEPKAR, war, dass die Amerikaner bei Bagdad und bei Mosul anfangen, große Abhörsturzpunkte aufzubauen, also so richtig große Abhörsturzpunkte mit jeweils ein paar tausend Mitarbeitern. Das war eine Story, die halt auf DEPKAR zuerst kam und die jetzt so nach und nach irgendwie doch auch mehr Bestätigung findet und die auch eigentlich genau zu dem passt, was man eigentlich erwarten würde, was sie da tut. Also insofern kann man wohl davon ausgehen, dass die möglicherweise wohl okay ist. Während des Golfkrieges gab es aber auf DEPKAR tausend Informationen darüber, wo sich Saddam Hussein heute gerade auffällt, die halt ganz offensichtlich einfach Unsinn waren. Und insofern muss man da halt immer so ein bisschen abwägen. Die Kunst dieser Abwägung geht tatsächlich wirklich am besten, wenn man es gemeinsam macht, das heißt, wenn man sich Informationen teilt und so ein bisschen versucht auch ein Gefühl zu entwickeln. Wiederum, es gibt andere Sites, wie zum Beispiel FNF.
Haben wir da auch ein deutsches Beispiel für solche Seiten, die da absichtlich fehlen Informationen, vielleicht sogar im Auftrag von Ihnen, nach www.prokost.de?
Also außer die klassischen Mainstream-Medien halt, kann man das schon durchaus nennen. Es gibt auch andere Möglichkeiten abzuschätzen, was die Glaubwürdigkeit von solchen Sachen betrifft, also gerade diese Meldungen, die da gerade waren über die leichten Unregelmäßigkeiten im amerikanischen Haushalt. Die sind in der Regel von Leuten, die es dann auch mit offiziellen Dokumenten belegen können, also die dann halt einfach hingehen mit Stream-information-Act und halt einfach versuchen, die Informationen aufzufinden und auch die Dokumente, die sie gefunden haben, halt einfach facsimile auf die Webseite tun, sodass man auch selber nachlesen kann, was dann da tatsächlich eigentlich passiert. Und was wir eigentlich wollen, ist ein bisschen darauf hinzuweisen, dass es diese, ich sag mal, alternative Nachrichten-Szene zunehmendermaßen gibt, sodass die heute in letzter Zeit entstanden ist und dass man da durchaus auch ein wesentlich weiteres Weltbild bekommen kann, als das, was halt eigentlich nur so in den normalen Nachrichten, die wir jetzt gleich wieder hören werden, übermittelt wird.
Ja, und vielleicht haben wir das Glück, nach den Nachrichten noch von euch Höhrenden den einen oder anderen Tipp zu bekommen, wo wir uns denn noch informieren können, wenn wir nicht Mainstream-Medien benutzen wollen. Die Nummer dafür ist 0331 70 97 110.
Fritz in Frankfurt oder? Dann 101, 5. Halbe 1.
Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht gehen die Temperaturen auf 12 bis 8 Grad zurück. Morgen wenig Wetteränderung. Es ist heiter bis wolkig, aber überwiegend trocken bei Höchstwerten und 22 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Garkow.
Eine Angestellte eines Kfz-Zulieferbetriebes hat an seinem Arbeitsplatz in Chicago sechs Kollegen erschossen. Der 36-jährige Mann soll angeblich wütend über seine Kündigung gewesen sein, sagte ein Polizeisprecher. Der nicht verhandeln wollte, stürmte die Polizei den Betrieb und erschoss den Mann. Die Bundeswehr soll ihren Afghanistan-Einsatz über Kabul hinaus ausdehnen. Mehr als 250 Soldaten sollen noch in diesem Jahr zusätzlich in die nordafghanische Stadt Kunduz verlegt werden. Das hat das Sicherheitskabinett in Berlin beschlossen. Voraussetzung ist allerdings, dass die UNO die Erweiterung des Mandats bildigt. Woody Allen hat mit seinem neuesten Streifen Anything Else, das 60. Film Festival in Venedig, eröffnet. 20 Filme bewerben sich um den goldenen Löwen. Dazu gehört Rosenstraße von Margarete von Trotter. Es ist der einzige deutsche Beitrag. Der Film handelt von Frauen im Berlin der Nazi-Zeit. Zum Sport. In der Champions League Qualifikation unterlag Borussia Dortmund dem FC Brügge mit einem 2 zu 4 im Elfmeterschießen. Damit darf Borussia Dortmund lediglich im OI Cup noch international mitkicken. Und in einem Nachholspiel der ersten Fußball-Bundesliga trennten sich Hannover 96 und Hansa Rostock 3 zu 3 unentschieden. Wir haben keine Verkehrsmeldung.
So klingt der Sommer in Berlin.
Auf der Fritz-Sommer-Hit-Fete. Mit zwei Dancefloors, mit Chillen im Columbia Fritz Sommergarten und mit ganz viel Sommer. Und wer in diesem Sommer an einem Samstag oder Sonntag Geburtstag hat, kommt mit sechs Freunden umsonst rein. Fritz die Sommer-Hit-Fete. Samstag ab 23 Uhr im Columbia Fritz Berlin.
Das ist Chaosradio 85, ein paar Minuten haben wir noch. Und gucken, wo wir Nachrichten lesen können, die nicht Nachrichten im Sinne von Nachrichten sind.
Also es geht auch gar nicht so darum, wo man jetzt die große Quelle hat. Also ist nicht so, dass wir euch jetzt hier einen anderen Gartenschlauch reichen, den ihr euch bitte ins Gehirn schiebt und wo dann alles rausfällt. Im Gegenteil, also was ich auch immer sehr auffällig finde, wenn man anfängt sich über alternative Quellen zu informieren, wie stereotyp die normalen Meldungen sind. Also ich fand es jetzt hier bei den gerade verlesenen Nachrichten zum Beispiel auffällig die Meldung über den einsamen Irren, der losgelaufen ist und Leute erschossen hat. Das ist so eine Meldung, die man im Grunde mit ausgetauschten Namen und Berufen und Altern so, weiß ich nicht, ein, zwei Mal im Monat hat. Und im Grunde jedes Mal die gleiche Story, nur halt andere Leute.
Aber immer in Amerika?
Ja, immer in Amerika. Das liegt daran, dass die Amerikaner einfach mehr von diesem Zeug publizieren. Also es gibt auch in Europa solche Fälle und die kommen auch in die News. Aber auffällig und besonders krass sind halt meistens die aus Amerika. Weil da einfach News Squads davon leben, dass sie solche Sachen rauspupeln. Und die werden dann halt danach bezahlt, als Erster am Markt zu sein. Also was ich sagen wollte, auffällig daran ist, wenn man sich alternativ informiert, da gibt es dann zum Beispiel so Meldungen wie jetzt, heute habe ich die gefunden. Da gab es einen Jungen, ein 15-jährigen, der war verzweifelt, stand in der Küche, hat sich ein Messer gegriffen und hat mit Selbstmord gedroht. Die Eltern waren auch verzweifelt, haben die Polizei gerufen. Polizei ist angerückt und hat den Jungen vor den Augen der Familie erschossen. Genau, solche Sachen. Und es war nicht das erste Mal, es war jetzt das dritte Mal, dass uns das passiert. In welchem Land? In Amerika natürlich. Also ich will sagen, die ganzen Meldungen, die man normalerweise in den Nachrichten hört, die sind schon selektiert in das Muster, was die Leute gewohnt sind zu hören. Das heißt, wenn man einmal anfängt, diese Art von Meldungen bei den Leuten zu bringen und dann gibt es halt Beobachtungen, was hören die Leute gern, oder was ist besonders populär, dann sind das eben immer die, ja, es gab hier einen Einsamirren, der hat Leute gecaptured und dann ist die Polizei heldenhaft gekommen und hat ihn einen Tag belagert und es dann hat sich durch den Garten eingegraben und hat ihn dann rausgeholt und die Geiseln befreit. Das wollen die Leute natürlich hören.
Ja, es ist Systemstabilisierung, das ist der Beweis dafür, dass die Exekutive funktioniert.
Aber der Punkt ist einfach, dass es so nicht immer funktioniert. Also ich habe jetzt keine Zahlen darüber, was jetzt häufiger ist, ob die Polizei häufiger erfolgreich ist oder nicht, aber es gibt eben viele Meldungen, wo dann eben das Gegenteil passiert. Und gar nicht mal so politisch gesehen, kann ich vielleicht mal eine Seite empfehlen, wo man immer solche funktioniert alles nicht Meldungen gibt, dass es farg.com, das ist eigentlich eher so eine, also ich will nicht sagen Satire-Site, aber die sammeln eben so Meldungen, wie eine Fußballmannschaft ist zum Beispiel passiert, da sind alle elf Leute von der einen Mannschaft, sind von einem Blitz umgelegt worden und die gegenüberliegende Mannschaft, solche Sachen passieren halt auch. Das gibt es dann vielleicht auch mal im Spiegel erwähnt. Also diese Art von Meldungen gibt es zum Beispiel zuhauf im Internet.
Wie schreibst du FARC?
FARC, F-A-R-K.
F-A-R-K.
Was halt auch noch relativ interessant ist am Internet, ist, dass man, sofern man enggespricht, auch in der Lage ist, sich die Perspektiven aus anderen Teilen der Welt anzugucken. Also es gibt ja seit einiger Zeit diese Site newsgoogle.com, wo halt einigermaßen, also vollautomatisch, Presseberichte aus aller Welt automatisch zusammensortiert werden. Da findet man dann immer diese schönen Meldungen, die Überschrift und dann die kurze Zusammenfassung mit einem Bild und darunter noch so den Link und so und so viel 100 weitere Artikel, die halt genau diesen Inhalt haben. Also Google sortiert halt sozusagen die Inhalte automatisch zusammen und generiert halt automatisch ein News-Site daraus. Das gibt es halt für, was weiß ich, Amerikas halt com, also international, es gibt auch newsgoogle.de, was halt die deutschsprachigen Medien sind. Und das gibt es halt auch für die ganzen anderen regionalen Medien. Da kann man halt sehr schön zum Beispiel mal gucken, was eigentlich gerade so in Asien diskutiert oder was halt so die Themen sind, die gerade in Indien diskutiert werden. Weil wann guckt man schon mal sonst in die Hindustan Times?
Ist übrigens sehr lohnenswert. Also die Deutschen gucken gerne in die neue Zürcher Zeitung, weil die halt deutschsprachig ist und auch so ein bisschen einen Blick aus dem Ausland hat. Aber wer Englisch kann, sollte das auf jeden Fall nutzen, um im Ausland zu gucken.
Also eine der Zeitungen, die ich wirklich regelmäßig gerne lese, ist die Asia Times Online, die halt gerade diesen ganzen Bereich Irak-Indien-Pakistan-Konflikt und so weiter und so fort. Eine Detailletiefe Karat, die man halt sonst kaum findet in europäischen Medien, wo halt einfach mal extrem überraschende Sachen drin sind.
Da liegt ja auch ein Jahr dran.
Zum Beispiel halt über die israelisch-indische Nuklearkooperation und ähnliche Dinge, die man halt einfach sonst in den Mainstream-Medien in Deutschland schon gar nicht findet. Also es ist schon so, dass man einfach mal hingehen muss und sich auch mal ein bisschen die Perspektive aus anderen Teilen der Welt schaffen muss.
Da reicht es ja bisweilen schon irgendwie nur die NZZ, die neue Zeug der Zeitung mal zu lesen.
Also es gibt so ein paar sehr... Wir sollten vielleicht einfach so stichpunktmäßig ein paar Sachen mal bringen, die uns so aufgefallen sind, wo wir gedacht haben, oh, das haben wir beim Spiegel nicht gesehen. Und eine Sache gerade, wo es hier um die Nuklearkooperation ging, eine Sache hatte ich zum Beispiel mal gelesen, aber auf einer chinesischen akademischen Uni-Zeitung zum Thema Weltraum, da stand dann drin, dass die Israelis ihren Spionagesatellit an Taiwan vermietet haben für den Zeitraum, wo die über China ist. Und das sind so Sachen, wo man denkt, aha, also das sind jetzt nicht unbedingt die weltbewegenden Meldungen für den typischen deutschen Einkaufstouristen, aber das sind einfach so Meldungen, die das Weltbild erweitern, weil man einfach sieht, aha, so ist das, oder dass Brasilien ein Weltraumprogramm hatte, das ist ja vielleicht auch dem einen oder anderen das erste Mal aufgefallen, als er jetzt in den News war, sodass ihm da ihr dritter Versuch explodiert ist. Also es gibt einfach so Meldungen, die man in Deutschland, in den normalen Medien gar nicht mitkriegt, oder erst dann, wenn es im Grunde zu spät ist. Und das ist eigentlich eine Sache, die sehr befriedigend ist. Wir sollten aber auch auf die Gefahren hinweisen, wenn man anfängt...
Warte mal, gibt es irgendwo vielleicht auf CCCD eine Linkliste zu all dem, was ihr da sprecht?
Na ich hab zumindest auf contramotion.com, eine Liste von landespezifischen Nachrichtenquellen, wo eben zum Beispiel die afghanischen, indischen, pakistanischen Zeitungen drin sind, wo man auf jeden Fall mal ganz schwer sein Weltbild relativieren kann, wenn man irgendetwas für objektiv hält. Heinz von Förster, um mal wieder einen Informatikbezug herzustellen, hat da gesagt, die Wahrheit ist die Erfindung eines Lügners. Einfach weil sozusagen Wahrheit ja impliziert, dass es auch Dinge gibt, die nicht wahr sind.
Es gibt vier Wahrheiten, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer es gesagt hat.
Ja, das ist diese andere Sichtweise. Ich glaube halt eher, es geht ja gerade darum, Realität aus Puzzle-Steinen zusammenzutragen. Aber natürlich sind so globale News, selbst in Indien, ich habe jetzt hier gerade so ein bisschen rumgeklickt, wird dann halt von diesem amerikanischen Fabrikarbeiter berichtet, der dann da mal quer irgendwie durch seine Kollegen geschossen hat. Das sind dann offenbar so globale Nachrichten auf einmal, dadurch, dass irgendwelche Presseagenturen gerade mal das Entertainment irgendwie durchschieben.
Der passende Satz dazu lautet, if it bleeds, it leads. Also wenn es blutet, ist es eine Schlagzeile.
Ja, also heute war gerade eine lustige Sache, fällt mir auf. Und zwar kam eine Story, dass die Amerikaner im Irak offenbar zu wenig Gewehre ihren Soldaten mitgegeben haben. Das heißt, die haben dann so Sachen gehabt wie eine Panzer mit vier Leuten und jeder hat eine Pistole und dann haben sie zwei Gewehre. Und das ist prima, solange die im Panzer sind. Aber wenn die außerhalb im Einsatz haben, haben die halt ein Problem ohne die Gewehre, weil die anderen haben halt irgendwelche automatischen Waffen. Und was die amerikanischen Soldaten jetzt tun, ist, dass sie da die beschlagnahmten Kalashnikovs einfach abgreifen und damit rumlaufen. Und das ist ja im Grunde schon eine Meldung, die relevant ist, für unser Bild von wie die amerikanische Besatzung oder die friedensstiftende Maßnahmen der Amerikaner im Irak funktionieren.
Naja, vor allen Dingen ist es eine Meldung, die relevant ist für die Leute, also zumindest die US-Amerikaner, die Kinder da unten haben, deren Kinder als Soldaten in diesem Krieg sind und die sich vielleicht immer noch einbilden, dass es denen gut geht.
Naja, da gibt es auch so viele Amerikaner nicht mehr.
Also sagt Spiegel online.
Also was man schon sagen muss, man kann ziemlich viel Zeit damit verbringen, sein Weltbild mal so ein bisschen zu erweitern natürlich. Was man dann aber auch relativ schnell sieht, sind so die Muster, da hilft Google News auch relativ stark, weil wenn man halt einfach dann so 317 gleiche Artikel sieht, die halt so durch die Weltpresse gehen, dann ist es halt okay, keine...
Na wir sollten sagen, woher das kommt, das ist ja kein Problem.
Das sind halt einfach die Agenturen, die halt einfach so die Replikation erzeugen. Aber oft genug wird halt einfach irgendwie nur Stereotyp reportet. Die Leute schreiben halt natürlich auch gerne voneinander ab und so weiter und so fort. Also die Ökonomie der Nachrichtenberichterstattung schlägt da natürlich auch zu. Worauf ich noch mal gerne zurück möchte, ist dieses Thema, was wir vorhin mit dem Christopher Albrighton hatten. Diese Subjektivität versus Objektivität in den Medien. Und was mir halt aufgefallen ist, dass ich mittlerweile Medienquellen, die mir sagen, dass sie nicht objektiv sind, sondern nur die subjektive Perspektive des Schreibers darstellen, eigentlich lieber mag als Medien, die von sich behaupten, objektiv zu sein, aber tatsächlich nicht sind. Also wenn ich jetzt mir so hingehe und mir so angucke, die normalen Mainstream-Medien versuchen alle, den Anschein von Objektivität zu wahren, mit einigen willigen Ausnahmen, wie z.B. Economist, der halt immer seine Meinung dazu schreibt, also da steht da drin irgendwie dieses Magazin, vertreten seit 1847 die Meinung, das, und das tun sie dann tatsächlich auch gar nicht. Das ist doch überhaupt ehrlich so, die sind halt einfach mal so die richtigen zynischen Kapitalisten, während alle anderen in der Regel versuchen halt zu sagen, naja, also das ist halt passiert und wir wissen halt, was passiert ist, und immer versuchen diese Autorität da durchhängen zu lassen. Und der Reiz gerade von den alternativen News-Quellen ist halt eben, dass das häufig nicht der Fall ist. Also da gibt es auch kommerzielle News-Sources, die halt, also einer der wesentlichen, die man einfällt, zum Beispiel Stratfor, das ist so eine kommerzielle News-Gruppe, die halt von ehemaligen Geheimdienstanalysen in Ameland betrieben wird, die halt relativ Ölindustrie fokussiert ist.
Einmalige Geheimdienst? Was soll das denn sein?
Na gut, also was es hier ist...
Also es ist eine Militär-Site, ganz ehrlich.
Nein, das ist nicht wahr.
Nein, es geht hauptsächlich um...
Nein.
Na sag doch mal, übersetz doch mal, was der Name heißt.
Strategic Forecast.
Ja, na eben.
Wer interessiert sich für Strategie? Nein, wie gesagt, ich sagte, die Jungs sitzen in Osten, Texas, also die sind halt Ölindustrie, das ist halt so deren Fokus. Und die machen es halt kommerziell, die haben halt auch ihren Bias da immer drin und den schreiben sie halt auch einfach rein. Und ich bin mittlerweile da angekommen zu sagen, okay, ich hab's echt lieber, wenn mir die Leute sagen, was ihre Meinung ist, weil dann kann ich mit dem, was sie schreiben, wesentlich mehr anfangen als mit so einem objektiv tunen, aber letzten Endes auch irgendwie vorbelasteten Reporting.
Aber bekommst du dann nicht irgendwann das Problem, dass du vor lauter Meinung vielleicht überhaupt nicht mehr die einfach die nackten Fakten erkennen kannst?
Ja, aber so ist es doch im Spiegel. Hör mal, die ganzen Leute, die den Spiegel lesen, glaubst du, einer von denen könnte dir so auf Anim sagen, das ist hier aber die Meinung?
Was ich meine, wenn ich den Spiegelartikel lese, muss ich als erstes gucken, wer hat den geschrieben. So, dann muss ich gucken, ob da jetzt gerade irgendwie der BND-Kontaktmann als Autor drunter steht, damit ich weiß, das ist jetzt eine Publikation vom BND. Oder ob jetzt irgendwie gerade der Kontaktmann zu dieser oder jeder...
Wie heißt der Kontaktmann zum BND, damit wir es alle wissen?
Könnten wir dir sagen, aber dann müssten wir dich erschießen.
Ja, kein Problem, ich werde eh bald erschossen.
Aber also, ich kann ja mal anonymisiert eine Geschichte, die ich von einem Mitarbeiter des Spiegel gehört habe, der hatte mal etwas veröffentlicht. Und dann klingelte, also auf Spiegel Online veröffentlicht, ein Dokument mit zu einem Artikel dazu. Und dann klingelte Minuten später das Telefon. Und ein sehr hochrangiger Mitarbeiter der Chefredaktoren war sozusagen am Telefon, der darauf drängt, dass dieses Dokument sofort entfernt wird. Man sei gerade in schwierigen Verhandlungen mit dem Bundesnachrichtendienst über dieses und jenes und würde da exklusiv Sachen bekommen. Aber dazu sei es eben nicht hilfreich, wenn da irgendwie Dokumente intern veröffentlicht würden und so fort. Und er meinte, was daran so erstaunlich ist, ist, dass es so offen mittlerweile läuft. Früher war es so, das war so ganz dezent. Die Rechtsabteilung hat angerufen, da sind rechtliche Bedenken aufgetaucht, ob nicht eventuell da jemand irgendwie klagen könnte gegen diese oder jene veröffentlichen. Und dann hat man das halt so dezent. Erstmal, weißt du, da gab es so einen Schimmer. Und heute ruft da einfach einer an und sagt, ey, ich sitze hier im BND, das geht nicht, weg damit. Und dass es so offen ist. Und das ist schon, wissen die Qualität. Und deswegen, ich meine, dem Spiegel oder auch anderen, denen man kann da irgendwie viel darüber Rätsel raten, was da sozusagen die Meinung ist, die dahinter ist. Aber die Auswahl macht es natürlich. Und die menschliche Aufmerksamkeit hat ja nun mal nur irgendwie ein beginstes Fassungsverfügen. Und ob unser Hirn dann wirklich so gut damit beschäftigt ist, sich mit irgendwie den sexuellen Vorlieben des Präsidenten zu beschäftigen oder mit anderen Dingen, das muss ja jeder selbst entscheiden. Sie wake the dog. Also das ist ja dann doch der Film, wie es eigentlich läuft. Um den mal zu empfehlen.
Ja genau, den muss man tatsächlich mal wieder empfehlen. Also dein Argument ist ja, dass die Medien tatsächlich die Fakten berichten, aber eigentlich ist ja nicht der Fall.
Nein, nicht dass sie tatsächlich die Fakten berichten, sondern ich habe immer die Befürchtung, dass wenn mir jemand zu viel Meinung aufdrückt, oder wenn ich hingehe und zulasse, dass mir jemand seine Meinung aufdrückt, dann laufe ich auch immer mit ein bisschen Gefahr, dass ich zulasse, dass er mir vielleicht auch verfälschte Fakten liefert.
Aber dann möchtest du es doch lieber wissen, oder?
Ja, aber...
Wenn er sagt, er verfälscht sie, okay, aber der sagt es ja nicht.
Nein, aber du musst sowieso immer davon ausgehen, dass die Sachen verfälscht sind.
Ja klar, aber du brauchst dir hier nur pakistanische und indische Seiten gerade anzugucken. Natürlich können die sich gerade auch auf der Berichterstattungsebene nicht leiden und berichten das jeweils schlimmste dem anderen zugeschrieben. Also völlig klar und entsprechend ist natürlich jede Zeitung eines Landes spiegelt natürlich auch ein bisschen den Kulturkreis wider. Das ist ja auch gut so. Man muss es halt nur sozusagen im Kopf haben, dass man...
Aber es ist richtig, das ist eine ernst zu nehmender Bedenken gegen das sich selbst informieren, dass man irgendwann, wenn man zu viele Quellen konsultiert, anfängt, eben nur noch die Stories für glaubhaft zu halten oder rauszusuchen, die sich eh mit dem eigenen Weltbild decken.
Nimm zum Beispiel ein schönes Beispiel, das ist doch Indymedia. Auf Indymedia lese ich 150 mal das Wort Bullen, anstelle von Polizei. Was ist daran ein schönes Beispiel? Natürlich ist Indymedia kein schönes Beispiel, das ist richtig. Aber ich lese beispielsweise 150 mal das Wort Bullen. Das macht mit mir, wenn ich denn einen weniger gefestigten Charakter habe, führt es dazu, dass ich grundsätzlich jeglichen Polizisten als Bullen und somit als verachtenswert ansehe. Das kann auch nicht sind.
Das muss durchaus Distanz schon waren. Indymedia ist nun tatsächlich ein gutes Beispiel dafür, wie unabhängige Berichterstattung grob entgleisen kann. So muss man einfach mal so sagen. Die amerikanischen Indymedia Ansätze, die waren gut. Da ist tatsächlich auch eine Menge interessante Sachen gelaufen. Irgendwann wurde das doch zu einer bestimmten Szene mit entsprechender Sprache gebraucht. So ist es mittlerweile Interim Online. Das kann man einfach gut ignorieren. Man braucht gerade Live-Berichterstattung vom 1.
Mai.
Dann geht man gezielt hin und holt sich die da. Aber das war dann auch schon.
Übrigens nur Indymedia Deutschland. Es kann durchaus interessant sein, sich z.B. Indymedia Spanien anzugucken. Da gab es sehr interessante Berichte über Sachen, die hier einfach auch nicht in den Medien waren. Die Bevölkerung hat sich da in weiten Teilen des Landes aufgelehnt gegen den Präsidenten von der Weile. Das war im Grunde da sehr gut zu haben. Indymedia Deutschland ist so ein bisschen entgleist. Indymedia insgesamt hat nachgelassen. Aber das ist auch wichtig, wenn wir schon anfangen, uns externe, also nicht Mainstream-Quellen zu suchen, dann impliziert das auch eine gewisse Dynamik. Da muss ich dann auch in der Lage sein, irgendwann zu sagen, diese Quelle ist jetzt verkommen. Es gibt sehr viele Quellen, also man muss nicht nur am Anfang, sondern ständig Arbeit und Zeit investieren, um sich da gute Sachen rauszupuppeln. Und ich möchte den Gedanken noch kurz zu Ende führen, es ist wirklich gefährlich, wenn man anfängt, sich praktisch nur noch die Meldungen rauszusuchen, die eh dem eigenen Weltbild entsprechen. Das kann auch in eine verschwörungstheoretische Angelegenheit entgleisen, dass die Leute dann irgendwie sagen, okay, das hab ich ja schon immer gesagt und hier steht es und da hinten steht es auch. Und das ist einfach so, wenn ich nach einer speziellen Idee oder nach irgendeinem, ob es jetzt tatsächlich Fakten sind oder nicht, nach irgendwas suche, im Internet werde ich irgendjemand finden, der das mal irgendwann geschrieben hat. Also das ist nicht alles wahr, was im Internet steht, auf keinen Fall, aber es ist trotzdem gut sein Weltbild zu erweitern.
Ja, plus, ich meine, damit hast du im Grunde aber nicht viel Kontrast jetzt erst mal zu normalen Medien. Ich meine, es war früher auch schon so, dass derjenige, der halt die ganze Zeit glauben wollte, dass die Welt aus Verbrechern besteht, der hatte halt XY Zimmermann geguckt und den entsprechenden Schund bei Rieders Deitschitz gelesen und derjenige, der glauben will, dass Osama Ben Laden des World Trades dann in Luft gesprengt hat, der glaubt halt Herrn Busch. Und ich meine, jede Information ist so viel wert wie die Quelle. So, und wenn man keine Quellenbewertung durchführen kann, aber das können ja nun ermäßig auch einige. Also ich glaube, ich sehe die Gefahr, die du damals einfach mal nicht so, sondern ich glaube die Gefahr viel größer ist, dass irgendwie man da sich nicht mehr bemüht, irgendwie objektive Fakten und anderes zu trennen. Auf der anderen Seite, ich meine klar kann ich jetzt wie Frank sagen, irgendwie ist cool, die Leute bei der Erdindustrie, die sagen halt, dass sie Arschlöcher sind. Und deswegen weiß man wenigstens irgendwie, wo ihre Interessen sind und wie ihre Nachrichten gefärbt sind. Aber auf der anderen Seite möchte ich es auch nicht missen, mit einer kulturellen, ganz anderen Betrachtungsweise von Indern, Pakistanis oder was auch immer, mir die Scheiße anzugucken.
Übrigens die Kramul Times ist richtig empfehlenswert.
Die haben einige echt coole Storys draus geraunt. Das hab ich bei Konzer Muschel auch ein bisschen versucht, teilweise, dass man da eben ein bisschen einschätzt, wo die religiös teilweise zum Beispiel so stehen. In Deutschland hat man ja auch so Zeitungen, da hatten wir doch mal diesen Herrn Dings da, in der Augsburger Allgemeinen Dings da, und da musste man dann auch erstmal gucken, wenn man auch diese Geschichte da weiß ja nicht wie, Mann, ist das ein katholisches Nest? Und da muss man dann auch in seinem evangelisch geprägten, irgendwie preußischen Glaubenssystem erst mal ein bisschen relativieren, was da so steht.
Ich bekomme regelmäßig und ohne, dass ich das überhaupt irgendwann mal verlangt hätte, ganz im Gegenteil, ich hab angerufen und darum gebeten, dass man es unterlässt. Ich bekomme nichts, desto trotz regelmäßig den rheinischen Merkur zugeschickt. Das ist eine Wochenzeitung.
Oh, ein Kampfflatt, ja.
Da wird dir aber ganz, ganz anders. Also das ist dann auch schon, ich sag mal, eine andere Sicht der Dinge, die man überhaupt nicht in seinem Leben haben möchte.
Was tut mir so?
Ich hab da so einen Grenzpunkt.
Da ist so Koch gläubig, sag mal mal so.
Ja, das ist so Roland Koch. Also das ist so christlich-konservativ, aber nicht christlich-konservativ. Also ich kenn genug christlich-konservative Menschen, die durchaus vernünftig sind. Aber das ist wirklich so schon ganz hart an der Grenze zu christlich-konservativen Kampfflatt.
Ah, die Fundis.
Ja, aber ganz, ganz unangenehm streckenweise. Eine Wochenzeitschrift.
Also wenn ich mal afghandaily.com, die Afghanistan Times empfehlen kann, beispielsweise auf der Titelseite einmal Herr Busch, Total Victory, Only Option in War on Terror. Und dann, für die Afghanis, ist der Bin Laden gerade in Pakistan. Nein, das ist super. Der Bin Laden, der wird von den verschiedenen Ländern, also den Zeitungen in den verschiedenen Ländern, immer so rumgeschoben. Wir waren es nicht. Nein, nein, der versteckt sich gerade bei dem, dem man nicht leiden kann. Und das ist also so herrlich, wie der Mann rumgeschoben wird. Wirklich wie so ein schwarzer Peter S. Ist ja nur nicht so schade.
Das ist wie mit den Massenvernichtungswaffen. Die sind jetzt nämlich auch gerade die neueste Meldung, nicht in Syrien, sondern im Libanon.
Habt ihr mitbekommen, dass das Auswärtige Amt mittlerweile Außenpolitik über Reisewarnungen auf der Homepage betreibt? Das war mir gar nicht klar. Ich hab das vor kurzem erst mitbekommen, dass obwohl in Kuba überhaupt keine Probleme sind, vor Kuba-Reisen gewarnt wird, weil die Bundesregierung gerade mit Kuba Probleme hat.
Wenn man versehentlich in Guantanamo Bay landet, kann das auch echt unangenehm werden.
Das ist nicht Kuba.
Also die Sache mit Kuba zum Beispiel, da gibt es auch noch den interessanten Hintergrund, warum die Bundesregierung gerade Probleme mit Kuba hat. Das liegt nämlich eigentlich nur daran, dass der spanische Ministerpräsident Asnar eigentlich ein Problem mit Kuba hat, weil irgendwie sein großer Onkel Bush ihm meinte, dass es vielleicht auch besser wäre, wenn er ein Problem mit Kuba hat.
Die digitalen politischen Beziehungen haben in jüngster Zeit eine spürbare Dynamisierung erfahren.
Das heißt so viel, wie jetzt geht es los.
Dynamisierung oder Dynamitis?
Die spanische Regierung tut halt in der EU alles, um die Beziehung zu Kuba zu verschlechtern.
Du meinst die Interessen der USA durchzusetzen.
So könnte man es formulieren. Es gab natürlich noch ein paar Menschenrechtsprobleme, aber die gibt es ja woanders auch.
Du meinst diese orangene Schlafanzüge. Du sagtest gerade, das ist nicht Kuba.
Guantanamo Bay liegt auf Kuba, aber das ist ja nun nicht Kuba.
Was für ein Staatsgebiet ist das denn?
Ich weiß nicht, gibt es für rechtsfreien Raum irgendeine Staatsbezeichnung?
Nein, es ist ja gepachtet.
Es geht zurück, habe ich heute nochmal nachgeguckt, es geht zurück ursprünglich auf Kriege zwischen Amerika und Kuba 1889. Da gab es einen Unabhängigkeitsvertrag mit Kuba, das war noch weit vor Fidel Castro, wo unter anderem drin stand, dass die Marines jederzeit einmarschieren dürfen und auch eine ständige Basis auf dem Grund und Boden von Kuba behalten. Und das war damals schon Guantanamo Bay und heute haben sie wohl einen Leasingvertrag gemacht und zahlen da auch tatsächlich Miete. Das ist total absurd. Was ja auch absurd ist, gerade über Guantanamo Bay kam heute eine schöne Meldung, dass die da den Drahtzaun auch immer gerade austauschen gegen Betonwände. Also die expandieren gerade und haben auch unter anderem ein Courtroom angebaut, damit sie schnell Leute da verurteilen können, weil da gibt es ja jetzt gesetzliche Basis für, dass man mit einem Militärgericht Leute mal eben hinrichten kann und dazu machen sie natürlich einen Raum, der ist gerade gebaut worden.
Wissenswerte ist über Guantánamo Bay, Kuba. Das Wissen wurde präsentiert vom Chaosradio 85 auf Fritz. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat gibt es das Chaosradio, nur nicht nächsten Mittwoch im Monat, weil nächsten Mittwoch im Monat sind wir im Flaming und senden da aus dem Flaming. Wann es also Chaosradio 86 gibt, ist noch nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Das diskutieren wir gerade mit der zuständigen Redaktion und werden das dann früh genug bekannt geben. Was wir allerdings wissen, ist, dass es jetzt den Nightflight mit Martin Peters drauf gibt, der steht draußen schon in den Startlöchern. Was möchtest du denn noch, Andreas?
Ich wollte nur ein Zehntelweis geben, dass ich nicht Andreas heiße. Das interessiert ihr natürlich auf ChaosradioCCCDE oder schlicht CCCDE und dann den Linksfolgen auch die Informationen zur nächsten Sendung und ich euch... Natürlich. Na ja, das kann man ja ruhig sagen. Und wir werden sicherlich auch noch ein paar Links zu dem, was wir hier erzählt haben, hinterherschicken auf der entsprechenden Seite.
Ich hab vorhin erwähnt, dass wir eine Mailing-Liste haben, die ist CCC-intern. Also nicht, dass ihr jetzt 100 Millionen Leute da aufschlagen. Sagen sie möchten ja ganz subscribed werden. Macht euch selber so eine Mailing-Liste.
Es gibt keine CCC-intern Mailing-Liste.
Nein, also die ist, wie soll ich sagen, die existiert nicht. Nein, macht euch eure eigenen Mailing-Listen, denkt für euch selbst. Wir denken nicht für euch, wir wollen auch nicht für euch denken. Ihr müsst da schon selber ran.
Im Studio verabschieden sich Felix, Frank und Andy. Außerdem Hannes, vielen Dank, dass du hier warst. Du bist von der Uni in Regensburg, Professor für IT-Sicherheitsmanagement und einer der Initiatoren oder der Initiator von JAP?
Ursprünglich war ich mal der Initiator von JAP, aber heute höre ich das natürlich nicht mehr so gern, weil ja so viele, viele andere Leute da mitmachen. Inzwischen sind es ungefähr 30, wenn man alle zählt, die jemals mitgemacht haben.
Vielen Dank, dass du hier warst. Und falls ihr Höhenden euch JAP runterladen wollt, dann tut ihr das bitte unter www.anon-online.de. Und jetzt aber ein Nightfly mit Martin Petershoff. Tschüss sagt Holger Klein.
Ich bin schon wieder da.